Four three,
two,
one,
ladies and gentlemen.
Jeff Novitsky.
How are you buddy?
What's up Joelle?
Doing good.
I have to ask you,
do you mind the nickname the golden snitch?
So first thing I was gonna bring up
this golden snitch bullshit.
I just want to say,
it's not my nickname.
It's Brennan jobs.
He came up with it 100% on his own.
He was going to ask you.
It's all good though.
It's good.
It's all good.
So a couple of funny stories about that.
So when did he come up with this?
About a year ago at least.
So,
so people in the office started coming up to me saying,
hey,
golden snitch,
what the hell's that?
Do a little research as she,
something about Harry Potter or some character named there.
I'm like,
what the hell does this have to do with me?
So about a month ago,
somebody lets me know,
hey,
checkout Wikipedia.
So for whatever reason there's a Jeff Novitsky Wiki pdf page.
You go to that page now it's so says,
actually my formal name,
Jeffrey John Novitsky,
Aka the golden snitch.
So last week,
Donna Marceline,
you know,
Donna,
um,
long 15 year employee of the UFC now works with me and talk about her little
later.
It's a great asset to what we're doing.
She sends me a text,
she says,
check this out.
So she's got one of those Amazon Echos.
Um,
Alexa,
I think so.
She says Alexa,
who's Jeff Novitsky and Alexis name says Jeffery.
John Novitsky Aka the golden snitch.
So thanks a lot.
Shop.
Oh,
shove.
What have you done?
That's hilarious.
I love Donna.
She's amazing.
She's awesome.
So she's over there.
Yeah,
I mean,
you know about kind of her history.
She was more of the five original ploys of the UFC was Dana as assistant to
start out with,
uh,
went on to become VP of event operations.
So basically,
you know,
she got everybody to the event set up hotel at the event,
ran the crew,
you know,
the blue shirts backstage that run the event.
Um,
you know,
I think after doing it for many years,
she got a little burnt out on it.
So when to Dana,
uh,
mid summer and says,
look,
I don't think I want to do this anymore,
but I'd really love to do something else and I've seen kind of what Jeff's doing
in his program.
I really like to go over there and work with him and kind of learn,
you know,
what he's doing.
And so Dana pulled me into the office and said,
Hey,
what do you think about this idea?
And it took me literally a half second to say 100% on board.
This woman,
I mean,
as you probably know,
is about as attention to detail and passionate about her work as anybody.
And really my positioning,
unlike the name,
the Golden Snitch,
is an advocate to our athletes to make sure our athletes are successful under
the program.
Not that they fail under the program.
It's definitely the wrong nickname.
It's just catchy.
It is just unfortunately catchy.
Again,
I'm all,
I'm all good with it.
I back.
But,
uh,
the real golden snitches,
Victor Conti,
he's the Golden Snitch,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
I was actually,
I can see that because he was a guy who was giving guys steroids.
You were a guy that was always catching people.
Correct.
So it's the wrong moniker.
Giving them steroids and then talking about it after,
right?
Yeah.
That's a snitch.
That's the golden stitch.
Not you man,
but it's all good.
I was hoping shop with him,
call him.
I'm up later in this show what I could do anything to them,
but it'd be interesting to look at him in the face.
He would say,
I'm sorry Bro.
Sorry.
Yeah.
Well anyway,
back to Donna.
She's awesome.
Um,
so I'm super psyched that she's with you.
So what exactly does she do for you guys?
Again her,
you know,
when I sat her down in the summer I said,
look,
your role here is going to make sure that the athletes are successful under the
program.
And in a program like this,
there are so many landmines,
you know,
whether it be making sure your whereabouts filing is that Tom is on time,
making sure you sought a,
knows where you're at so they can come do a collection from you at any time.
Uh,
making sure you make safe supplement choices,
making sure the medications you're taking are correct.
So she,
you know,
works hard for all those things.
I give you the prime example of what she brings to this program.
So every three months,
every quarter,
every single athlete on the roster is required to file what's called quarterly.
Whereabouts.
Can I pause right here?
It does.
Just so this can be a standalone if people don't know exactly what you do.
Sure.
Jeff is in charge of making sure that all the UFC athletes are clean and free of
performance enhancing substances.
And it was a huge issue before you came along.
A huge issue in the sport.
And,
and continues to be in other organizations,
particularly overseas.
I mean there's just ramping speculation about companies that literally encourage
people to take steroids.
It was always the case with pride in Japan.
That was one of the big things about pride ensin anyway,
who fought for them many times came on the podcast and literally was saying in
the contract and like capital letters,
it says we will not test you for steroids.
Like they wanted everybody to take steroids.
They,
I had friends who went to fight over there.
They told him to take steroids and move up a weight class.
So it was always an issue in the sport that this was a dirty sport air quotes.
Right.
Yeah.
Um,
but since you've come along and since you guys started instituting this
incredibly strict testing,
we've seen some pretty radical changes.
We've seen some amazing fights and amazing performances and I don't think the
performance levels dropped.
In fact,
I think it escalated and elevated rather,
which is something that people were really concerned about.
But one thing that we did see is some people that you suspected of doing stuff,
their bodies radically changed.
It was really mean.
That became a meme pre Usada and post Usada I mean,
and there's some comedy memes out there because of it,
because people's bodies change so radically.
Yeah,
it's interesting.
You know,
the last time I was on,
we talked about kind of the smell test,
looking at somebody and you know,
it's difficult to say definitively whether or not,
you know,
changes
in bodies are due to that or not,
but you know,
you can't help but look at some of these pictures before and after you saw it.
And I think that's the case.
That's something I always struggle with.
How do you judge the success of a program?
Um,
you know,
do you judge it on numbers of positive tests?
I don't think that's necessarily the case.
You know,
maybe,
maybe you're not catching everybody.
Maybe there's no one to catch.
Um,
do you judge it on before and after pictures?
I don't know.
I mean that,
that could be one factor.
I like to judge it a lot anecdotally.
You know,
a big part of my job is getting out and building relationships with our
fighters,
with managers,
with coaches,
and just,
you know,
chewing on their ear and figuring out what they're seeing and what they're
hearing.
And almost universally,
the feedback I get from,
from them is this is making a big difference.
Um,
you know,
one thing I brought with me today,
and really the coolest piece of data I think I've seen in any anti-doping
program are some really objective measurable statistics and the UFC anti-doping
program Usada so you saw it as the United States antidoping agency.
They're the official antidoping agency of the United States by an act of
Congress.
They're in charge of all drug testing for us Olympic sports.
Uh,
back in 2015 we made the decision to outsource the administration of our program
to Usada.
The primary reason being the independence factor.
Um,
you know,
when you look at all these other professional sports league,
some have,
you know,
better programs and other none really have any independence in the
administration.
That program.
And with that means is there's no way of telling whether or not,
um,
you know,
when an athlete is sanctioned,
it's done for business reasons or done for favoritism.
So in our program,
you know,
no one can say that that any of the administration of our program has done for
that reason.
It's a truly independent authority.
So what you saw it did recently as they went back and they'd been in existence
since I think about 2001 on the US Olympic level.
They went back and took a look at every single doper I think for steroids.
Everyone was caught for steroids in the existence of the Usada program and took
a look at each of those athletes,
biological passports and biological markers and they looked at what was the most
common factor for the doper versus you know,
the non doper.
And what they determined was what stood out the most was large variance in
testosterone excretion in the urine.
And we think about it,
common sense point of view that kind of makes sense and that someone who's using
steroids at that time presents a sample.
Their testosterone excretion is probably going to be on the higher end.
And if they were to catch a doper on and off cycle,
what happens when you get off steroids is your body suppresses production of
testosterone.
So in that case you're going to see a very low excretion of testosterone.
So they looked at that and plotted it out and saw hey,
every dope or has a very large variance and testosterone excretion.
Then what they did is they took all the UFC samples and they plotted amount by
quarter and actually brought a graph along with me.
And it's some really drastic,
I think,
visual evidence of the success and the impact of this program.
I don't know if you can throw it up mom to take a look at it.
Um,
so when,
what year exactly did,
uh,
you saw a takeover?
Yeah.
So we can't,
you saw it,
it came into play July of 2015 so if you saw it has been in existence for two
years.
So you see here,
um,
that first quarter,
quarter three of 2015,
a pretty decent variants there.
Um,
which means in any given test and athlete,
you know,
I was up on an average,
a little bit 30,
I'm a little,
you know,
in the mid twenties.
And then look at,
as you plot out that graph,
uh,
that variance becomes smaller and smaller and smaller and more in the medium
range as it gets out to,
you know,
quarter three of 2017.
That's very interesting.
You don't,
you don't,
this is,
you don't usually see statistics.
This is the first I've been involved in anti-doping world since 2002 and I can
unequivocally say that this is the strongest visual,
objective,
measurable evidence of success of a program that I've ever seen.
Well,
one of the things that's so fascinating about this,
and um,
this,
this goes to this,
goes to credit to the UFC 100% is that they decided to do something about this.
They didn't have to,
it wasn't like someone coming after them because,
uh,
you know,
so many people had been caught and someone said,
hey,
we're going to put a program on you guys to make sure you're not doping.
Or the UFC said,
we've got to clean this up and there's,
there's only one way.
The one way is to go with the very best testing possible and the most rigorous,
the most,
I mean checkin everywhere you go,
we're going to give you random tests,
six o'clock in the morning,
knock on your door,
like the whole,
the whole full gamut of tests and the results have been pretty amazing.
And that alones that speaks volumes when you see this size of the variance
between the,
uh,
the test when you guys first started versus now definitely,
hey,
it's a credit to two people,
the Renzo for Tita and Dana white that made that decision and that's a hell of a
risky decision but done for all the right reasons.
You know,
anybody that contends that Dana doesn't care about his athletes need look no
further than this program.
This program is of tremendous risk to the company and to the bottom line.
When you're test athletes 365 days a year on announced no predictability of when
the test is coming,
there can be some very severe consequences to have been there.
Several main events there has been,
I mean,
UFC 200,
yeah,
the land,
arguably the landmark event in the history of the UFC.
We lose our main event,
the before
UFC 200 millions if not tens of millions into the marketing of that.
Um,
you know,
the success of the paper view probably hinges on that great main event between
John and Daniel and we lost it three or four days before.
And that could happen.
Didn't you know,
at any given moment.
Now we talked about this before the podcast,
um,
what you could or could not talk about what the current state of John Jones
investigation.
So where's it at right now?
Yeah.
So,
you know,
generally we don't talk about,
uh,
the case.
So,
so how the process works.
When an athlete test positive you sought it will notify me.
Um,
I usually pick the phone up right away and call Dana and let him know and the
UFC puts out an announcement.
They say,
you know,
in the case of John John tested positive,
uh,
then in an in competition test on this date,
um,
you know,
more information will be provided.
At the appropriate time.
That's generally all we'll talk about.
Now.
If the athlete chooses to talk about,
you know,
scenarios of,
of what happened,
then they're free to do that.
Um,
at that point you saw it in the UFC can comment on it.
So there's been some things talked about in the John Case,
uh,
by John.
Um,
particularly he had to clean tests on July 7th and July 8th before his positive
test on I think July 30th,
which was way in day.
And the positive test was for to hydro chloral methyl testosterone or oral
Terenna ball.
Um,
this is a substance that was used by the East Germans.
I'm regularly in the late sixties,
and then came into the fold a little bit more,
um,
of what's come out recently a matter of Russia.
So,
um,
I know you had a Bryan Fogel on for,
for the ICARUS moving.
I think you talked about a little bit about this.
Um,
uh,
Gregory,
the head of the Moscow,
a laboratory that this drug became kind of part of his protocol,
um,
with his athletes.
He then ironically enough developed a test for the longterm metabolites of the
drug.
So previous to that,
the detection window of this drug was a couple of days.
So it was a drug that you know,
even if you run a strict program,
an athlete may gamble with taking because it had a quick clearance time after he
discovered the longterm metabolite test that changed and went from a detect and
when detection window of a couple of days to a detection window of several
months.
And this was widely known,
you know,
it wasn't a secret.
Initially they kept it quiet and they went back and retested some samples and
there was a whole bunch of positives and then it got out 2013 around that there
was this new test.
So right up front,
you know,
I've,
I've said this a while now is,
would not make a lot of sense for an individual,
a UFC athlete that new,
you know,
especially,
a champion contender like Jon Jones at new and I'm tested quite regularly in
this program,
would not make a lot of sense that that would be your drug of choice.
If you were intentionally trying to cheat,
um,
I think it's come out after the fact that,
uh,
you saw the,
did another test on John a month or two or a couple months after his positive
tests and he was negative during that test.
So that would be indicative that,
you know,
the prohibited system entered his system or the prohibited substance entered his
system,
you know,
sometime after July 7th or eighth and was likely,
a pretty small amount in that it cleared his system pretty quickly.
Um,
again,
you know,
who knows where it plays out,
but certainly on the surface of things I have said,
you know,
at this point in the game with that type of information out there,
um,
it wouldn't indicate the intentional use.
Now that could be wrong.
I don't know that definitively.
And,
and we'll see how this plays out.
Uh,
right now where the process is as John and you saw that are working closely,
um,
I'm aware that there was a meeting a week or two ago,
pretty lengthy meeting,
which,
uh,
I was told was productive.
It wasn't given details of what productive meant.
Um,
but I think that's an important thing right now.
And that John's falling through with his to retrace all of his steps between
that,
you know,
last July 8th positive tests and our negative tests and the positive test on
July 29th of July 30th.
It certainly seems like,
based on what you just said,
that this is something that was accidentally taken,
but if you can't prove that something was accidentally taken,
like if you can't nail it down,
what do you,
what happens there?
Yeah,
it's,
it's difficult and that's,
you know,
that's kind of the nightmare scenario that a lot of,
that an athlete can face in a big roll of what Donna and I do to prevent that
from happening,
to show them what type of care and consideration is needed to make sure you
don't get into a scenario like that.
You know,
under a program like this,
you have to be careful about everything that's put into your body and
everything.
And,
uh,
if you're not,
there can be,
you know,
severe consequences.
Um,
so yeah,
we'll,
we'll see where this plays out.
I tell you,
the one thing that I,
that I can say about this is,
you know,
this is obviously John's second time I'm in the program with testing positive.
And in the first time he went through a pretty lengthy,
um,
appeal process and there was a publicly issued a decision,
50,
60 pages that went through all the evidence that,
that the independent,
um,
uh,
arbitrators heard and decided on.
And what they said definitively in that case was John,
there was no evidence of John intentionally cheated,
however he operated with careless,
reckless disregard.
Um,
so we ended up getting the maximum for that,
for those substances you tested positive for a year.
And that was for some gas station Viagara type shit,
not well,
it was actually a couple of anti estrogen drugs.
But what was shown and what the evidence pointed to was that he took a pill that
was manufactured from a website by the name of all American peptide.
Uh,
the pill was reported to be a Cialis pill.
So when erectile dysfunction pill that was tainted with these two drugs.
Now,
the problem with the arbitrator said is if he would have gone to that website
and the arbitrators did and I did,
you would have seen that that same website offered,
you know,
tons of performance enhanced,
prohibited performance enhancing drugs.
And the website said,
you know,
not for human consumption,
for research purposes only.
So it really was careless disregard that being said.
However,
John's,
you know,
second time through the program now the second sanction this time for,
an anabolic type steroid would have,
you know,
a starting point potentially have a four year suspension.
That's a starting point that that could be a starting point,
right?
Unless there are mitigating factors.
Now I don't,
you know,
again,
the beauty of this program is it's not the UFC or not me deciding what the
sanctions going to be.
No one can accuse us of,
you know,
operating for business purposes or favoritism or whatever.
Um,
but that being said,
you know,
when we put this program together and figure it out,
what sanctioning would look like.
I don't necessarily think that we put up a four year sanction,
uh,
for a second term offense when the first term of fence was shown that that
person didn't cheat,
intentionally,
just operated with careless disregard.
So who makes that distinction then?
You saw the shotgun,
makes that distinction.
They,
you know,
they have a whole team looking at it.
They compare it to other cases under the Wada,
uh,
Olympic type umbrella,
similar cases.
Um,
I will say this,
that,
you know,
I think we've had a few over 60,
um,
positive adverse events in this case and those that have been adjudicated.
I've been comfortable every time that they've made a fair and balanced and
reasonable decision.
And that's part of my job is to be the eyes and ears for athletes to make sure
not only is the program being administered properly and has strength,
but also that they're being treated fairly and that they have due process.
So I have all the confidence in the world.
However,
this does come out that it will be the right decision.
The other really cool thing about the program is the transparency the program.
So,
you know,
it won't just be me saying this,
however it does come out,
whether it goes to arbitration or whether John and you sought or reach a
settlement,
it'll be well spelled out about why that sanction,
uh,
was determined.
Now you say starting point,
meaning that it could potentially be more,
it could.
So,
uh,
when there's something called aggravating circumstances,
so more than just knowingly taking the drug,
taking the drug and lying,
trying to cover it up,
taking multiple drugs,
one trying to hide the other.
Yeah,
you could,
you could get double,
um,
uh,
the sanction amount.
So,
um,
you know,
on a second time,
anabolic steroid for years is kind of the starting point.
You can go lower for mitigating factors.
You can go higher for aggravating factors up to eight years.
Um,
so yeah,
I mean it would have to require something,
you know,
really severe degree just to get to get up that bad high.
Has anybody ever gotten that hit?
Not In the UFC program.
Now,
what is the biggest hit that anyone's ever gotten in the Yoh side?
I think thus far it's two years.
And it was that,
um,
I think a few people,
uh,
Chad Mendez comes to mind.
Chad Mendez,
his was some sort of psoriasis cream or something.
His was an insulin growth factor one.
So IGF one.
And did he say that it came from a psoriasis Korean?
I think he may have said that.
Yeah.
That was never proven or no,
I mean there was nothing and you saw it as reasoning or their announcement of
why it was two years about you know,
any type of mitigating factor coming from,
cause I know he your sunrises and someone had said or had red,
I didn't really investigate very deeply into this,
but I remember reading that he had put some sort of cream on and then that creem
was responsible for him testing positive.
Was that?
Yeah.
I don't know that's the case.
I do recall him saying that.
But you know,
hey an athlete can say anything they wanted about why it happened.
If there was something mitigating,
they are afforded that right to share with Usada that,
look I didn't do this on purpose.
It wasn't on the label,
the cream.
Usually in those instances where the evidence does show that you will see,
you know,
a mitigating factor come into play and a reduction in a sanction.
There wasn't any,
in that case it was the two years and there have been some guys that have gotten
pretty low sentences.
Like Tim means is a good example,
right?
Tim Means did take something that was tainted and you guys or you sought a,
got some of those samples from independent stores found out those were also
tainted.
Yeah,
Tim means took a supplement.
It was a Kreatin.
Um,
and you know,
after he tested positive,
and again,
this is where Donna and I come into play quite a bit,
you know,
when athletes test positive,
we reach out to them right away saying,
look,
we're here to help you here.
If there's help to be had,
uh,
will believe you tell you,
give us a reason not to.
Um,
I did that with Tim.
Tim said I'd never heard of this substance.
Jeff,
I,
you got to believe me.
I didn't take it.
Said,
all right,
well let's start doing retracing steps.
What have you been taken?
Um,
he sent me,
you know,
maybe a half dozen supplements,
did some research on them,
worked,
uh,
reached out to kind of contacts I still have in the,
in the industry from my law enforcement days and said,
hey,
any of these kind of raise suspicions.
And there was one that did buy a company that made some other kind of sketchy
products.
Um,
we narrowed in on that one pretty quickly Senate to Usada too.
A lot of laboratory tested it.
Sure enough it had the substance in it.
Um,
then what happens is you saw it a will independently procure some themselves.
So outside of the kind of touch of the athlete to make sure the athletes not
contaminating with it for Brighton excuse,
they were able to get some that was sealed and not opened.
And sure enough it,
it had that substance in it and it had the same amount of the substance in it
that kind of matched up with how much was in Tim system.
And when he said he had taken it last.
So there's a lot of detective work that comes into it and I get,
I get this question a lot from fighters saying,
hey,
the supplement excuse is a bullshit excuse that,
you know,
there's athletes use and stuff and they have supplements in their closet that
they know are tainted and then boom,
if they test positive,
they just have that built in excuse.
And what I tell them is it,
it's,
it goes deeper than that.
There's literally detect scientific detective work that's going on from the
Usada side,
making sure everything matches,
making sure they independently procure the product,
making sure what turns up in the Athlete's system based on when they say they
were taking it matches exactly the level that's in the product based on,
you know,
metabolism timings.
So it's much more than that.
And I,
I do have a lot of confidence when you saw it,
it says,
Hey,
it does match that this is,
you know,
came from an unknowingly or unintentional ingestion that it really is that now
in a case like Tim means,
why is he suspended,
is if someone does give him a tainted supplement and he takes it in good faith
thinking that it's just creating,
right?
So,
so there are strict liability in the program and you know,
they look at all the factors.
So,
you know,
creatine is a relatively low risk product.
However,
the Kreatin Tim took was not third party certified and that,
you know,
get a lot of questions about,
man,
the supplement industry is dangerous.
And you know,
this sucks for,
for athletes.
There's nothing they can do.
There is something that you can do and it's actually pretty simple to do.
Um,
we were talking earlier about,
about on it,
um,
a company you're,
you're involved with and,
and you guys third party certify a lot of your product.
And what that means is you outsource random testing of the product and sampling
of the product,
um,
from these independent companies to make sure they contain no prohibited
substances.
And you know what don and I educate our athletes too,
is you can go to these third party certification companies.
I think you guys use Catlins group banned substance control group.
There's that group.
Um,
there's informed choice.
there's NSF for sport and you can go to their websites and they have lists of
all certified products and there's hundreds of them.
So there's,
there's no excuse that you can't find as,
you know,
UFC athlete products that are tested in an independently certified as banned
substance free.
And if it were the case,
and it's not saying that it couldn't happen because those companies aren't
testing every single bottle of product.
But if you're an athlete,
you take a third party certified product,
you record it,
you log it,
and it turns out to be from that product.
I think then you're reaching a level where the mitigating factors maybe do get
you down to no sanction,
you know,
a public warning or something.
Hey,
you know,
maybe you shouldn't use supplements at all type of thing.
Right?
So his error was just taking something that was not third party section and just
not doing his homework.
When a company there's a responsibility for something like that,
six months,
it seems like a lot.
But in reality most it's a really,
he's really only got about three months off because most fighters after a fight
are going to take a few months off anyway.
I mean it seems harsh but there is,
there is an obligation that fighters need to do their homework and you need to
have a bit of a deterrent there to make sure they do it.
And,
and that's that deterrent.
Now,
one of the things that I thought was really cool about the EOC performance
institute,
which is just,
that's a,
there's so much cool about that place,
but one of the things that was really cool is that you guys have a station where
an athlete can go in and check any sort of substance,
any cold medication,
they're taking anything type in the name of it.
And it'll tell you on this like giant tablet,
whether or not what you're taking is band.
Yeah,
it's,
so it's,
it's a kiosk.
So as you sought a kiosk and we have like a little iPad in there and it's
between the locker rooms and the recovery room.
So it's United got your hot cool and your pole cold pool,
um,
and your sauna and your cryo and all that stuff.
So it's a constant reminder as our athletes are in that flow between that area.
Cause they all walked through there every day that you saw it as a part of this
sport,
that we're a clean sport,
that you have an obligation to check on medications,
supplements and you have an obligation to file your whereabouts.
They can also file whereabouts at that kiosk.
And we get athletes all the time walking down that corridor or saying,
Oh shit,
I forgot to tell you sod.
I flew out to Las Vegas at the Pi.
Boom.
They can get on in a minute or two and update where they're at.
So I have an APP,
they do.
So,
um,
so they can update by APP.
So it's on your phone as well.
So every quarter,
athletes are required to get on a through a web browser,
what's called the quarterly you saw to whereabouts filing.
They usually have to watch an instructional video most of the time reminders
about smart supplement choices,
um,
things like that.
And then they tell you saw to where they're going to be for the next three
months.
And most of the time,
hey,
I mean I do Donna and I do the whereabouts filing as well and we both say,
Hey,
who knows where I'm going to be next week,
let alone two or three months from now.
But you make your best guess at it.
And then all that information you put,
uh,
through the web browser is downloaded to your mobile phone app.
So to,
as your plans change over the next couple of weeks,
couple of months,
you can do 45 second to one minute updates through your mobile app.
Um,
so the convenience is there.
There's really no excuse and not letting you saw to know,
um,
where you're at.
There are repercussions if you don't let them know where you're at.
Um,
because you want to avoid somebody,
you know,
ducking and dodging a test.
But no cowboy had a situation where he was actually in Vegas at the fights and
they were mad at him cause he didn't say that he was going to be in Vegas.
He's like,
I'm at the fucking fights,
I'm right here.
I'm on TV.
Don and I do everything we can to try to let you saw to know that when we know
that a fighter has a UFC obligation,
so whether they're our guests fight or on the road,
whether they're,
you know,
add a competition,
we're always passing that information along to you saw that.
But we also tell them that ultimately it's your responsibility as an athlete
will try to,
but you know,
we can't guarantee it ultimately was going to fall on you if you don't update.
Now the good thing about this,
as you're afforded a couple of mistakes under the whereabouts program,
so it's not until three whereabouts,
failures in any rolling 12 month period that there can be sanctions.
Because honestly,
I mean,
things happen in your life.
Everybody's human.
Sometimes you forget.
I'll give you the perfect example.
So again,
getting back to Donna,
the most,
um,
attention to detail person that I've ever worked with him at working career,
she comes over joints,
kind of our program here.
We get her signed up for whereabouts.
She was like,
this is great.
Like I can talk knowledgeably about how to do this.
We went out to Anaheim for UFC,
I forget what number that was.
Um,
we take a trip down from Anaheim to San Diego.
We went down to this clinic that we were checking out for brain therapy.
She forgot to update that she was going to San Diego.
She was more than two hours outside of where she was supposed to be,
where you sought a new shoe was going to be,
she would've gotten a whereabouts failure again.
One of the mills responsible people that I've ever been around goes to show that
it's challenging and in,
so she has to notify where she's going to be.
We do it voluntarily just so we can talk knowledgeably to our athletes.
So when they say,
oh,
this is too hard,
or you know,
we say,
well we do,
we do it right?
Yeah.
Here's,
here's a little trick that I had to remind myself,
you know,
each day where I said I'm going to be at things like that.
Now when you have a fighter like a Holly Holm I think said she was tested nine
times in preparation for this fight against Cyborg.
When,
when that happens,
is there a,
I know you can't say when the test is going to happen because it won't be
random,
but is there any consideration about the sleep cycle of the fighters?
Yeah,
I mean that's,
you know,
you saw it.
It never lets me know when a test is coming.
I have zero input in terms of who's being tested and that is the reality.
A lot of times they show up five 36 in the morning show up,
really suck if fighters,
there is no doubt about it.
The bird and this,
the urine,
this is it.
Just a urine test can be blood as well.
I mean,
imagine you're dead asleep.
Six in the morning,
someone's knocking at your front door.
That's scary shit to begin with,
right?
You go downstairs,
you know,
you're trying to get ready for a fight,
prepare yourself,
sleep wise mentally,
and you've got to have a needle stuck in.
You had to get to draw blood,
wait until you got to take a pee.
Could be,
you know,
some fighters wait hours.
Um,
you know,
I don't think enough attention is being paid to the burden that's on the
athletes and the credit.
They should be getting a Holly Holm.
I think I saw,
it's just a statistic that she's the most tested athlete since the inception of
the program.
I think she's around 32 or 33 samples that she's provided.
I mean,
that's crazy.
Um,
but that I think she should not enough credit is given to her.
Nobody,
they test her so many times because she know,
I haven't heard any suspicions of her being no,
neither have I.
And you know,
I think as you look at the testing statistics,
and that's another cool thing about program.
I don't know if you know that,
but all these tests,
numbers are publicly available.
So the transparency and this program is unprecedented,
unparalleled as it comes to professional sports.
There's no other professional sport on the planet where you or I as a fan of the
UFC could say,
let me see how many times Holly's been tested,
how many times Cyborg's been tested.
That's unparalleled.
Um,
but if you look at those numbers and allocation,
we look at them.
I think those athletes with staying power,
those athletes that are at the tops of their division have more tests directed
to them versus,
you know,
athletes at the bottom that are jumping in and out.
They want to make,
I think you sought a good use of their resources to make sure that they're
directing most of those tests.
Those athletes are going to be around for awhile.
And I mean,
we saw what a bad ass Holly is on,
on Saturday night.
That woman's incredible.
And uh,
you know,
I think Sida probably realizes that too.
And she's going to be around for a while and wants to set,
you know,
an example,
and I tell athletes a lot,
I say,
hey,
we're,
this is a badge of honor.
You know,
I know it's a burden,
but man that makes you even more special of an athlete that you,
you know,
take that burden on and embrace it and,
and show the world that you're,
you know,
not only a bad ass athlete but you're doing this clean.
And one of the things that I thought was really fascinating about the UFC
performance institute is that machine will,
you lie down and it scans your entire body and it shows where your muscle
imbalances are and like what,
what are,
what are all the different details I think focuses on.
Yeah.
I mean we talked about this when he toured it,
but you've got to get,
you've got to get some of the personnel from the Pii in there that can really
talk knowledgeably and have,
you know,
that education,
I'm going to bring those guys in.
They're going to come on.
Not only is that,
as you saw at that facility world class,
but they staffed it with the perfect worldclass personnel.
So that machines called a Dexa scan and you know,
I can't give it the justice that the personnel can there,
but it yet measures body composition.
So it will measure,
you know,
fat,
um,
hydration levels,
bone density,
and as it is it,
how's it doing that some type of low level x-ray.
Again,
you got to get those guys in there to describe it specifically.
But you know,
I'm sure as a topic we'll cover today the whole weight issue being in the proper
weight class and weight cutting the both the,
the equipment and now the personnel in place of the performance institute that
there's no excuse for an athlete to not a fine their way,
right way class and B,
you know,
safely,
efficiently,
you know,
meet that weight goal.
Um,
when they're fighting,
everything is in place now there for that.
Now when a fighter comes to you guys and,
and lies down in that machine and,
uh,
you read their hydration levels and say they're slightly dehydrated and yet
there's still 10 pounds above the weight class,
how do you handle that?
So we have a director of sports nutrition guy by name of Clint Wattenberg and
uh,
Clint was a division one all American at Cornell,
Ivy League educated,
smart as hell.
Uh,
went on to wrestle with team USA.
It's actually wrestled with a lot of our fighters have had several conversations
about with guys that,
that wrestled him before Clinton came here.
So he's got,
you know,
a ton of pure respect for that.
I'm Super Smart Guy,
but yet he works,
you know,
he'd be the guy to ask.
He's,
you know,
Ivy League educated,
um,
in sports nutrition and in a situation like that,
that he's,
you know,
given advice to the fighters about how the importance of hydration and trying to
change that around so that they can meet those goals.
Yeah,
there's the machine right there.
Um,
what is it called?
Dual energy x-ray absorbed appsource beyond tree.
How do you say that?
We call it Dexa scan,
sore geometry.
That sounds like something that like someone would say in a cartoon,
like a fake word.
It measures body composition including lean mass,
muscle tissue,
fat mass and bone density.
Measuring and tracking all three of these components is important for weight
class sport athletes and helps guide nutrition recommendations.
Fascinating stuff.
So,
um,
it just sort of scans over.
Yeah.
How long has that test take?
A,
you don't,
I've never gone through it or actually never seen it.
I've got to get over there and check it out.
I Dunno.
It was interesting with Forrest was t doing,
Forrest Griffin was telling me that uh,
when he had it done,
he found out that one of his legs has two pounds more muscle than the other leg
because he had had some knee injuries and you really had no idea.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
I mean,
so,
so forest is a big part of that.
Performance Institute was a big part of,
you know,
touring other facilities around the world.
I think him and James Campbell,
who's our VP of operations at the Pii,
went to 61 or 62 facilities throughout the world and took would they believe
were the best parts of these facilities and put them all to one and forces role
there.
Um,
is,
you know,
kind of similar to my role in the anti-doping program and advocate for our
athletes.
He's there to make sure as a former fighter knowing what works and what doesn't
work.
Um,
we're looking at a video of this thing right now and it looks like star trek is
it,
what does it saying anything Jamie,
very end of pans over and shows what shows up on the screen.
There's a coming in like bunches of different data points.
This is amazing.
Yes.
I mean I talked to you I thought maybe last week and get you out there earlier,
but you got to come.
I'm going to next time.
Next time in March should come day or excuse me a day early.
Just do,
they'll put you through the whole thing.
We get you get your Dexa scan done,
your body composition.
You then have a meeting with Clint,
talk about nutrition and goals.
Maybe go see the physical therapist,
talk about any issues you have and therapy you need.
Go work out with our strength and conditioning coach both Sandovall it puts you
through the,
the ringers and the equipment there and then do a little recovery after that
that really gave you the full experience.
Yeah,
that place is amazing how you guys get it set up and it's,
it's really,
uh,
a massive resource for fighters that if,
because there's a lot of great Jim's out there,
but I don't think I've ever seen one that's that well equipped that you guys
have everything.
You have a complete strength and conditioning system,
uh,
area.
And then you have a complete area for,
with heavy bags,
a cage boxing ring,
and then you have a complete recovery area.
You have cryo machines,
you have that,
what does that light machine?
Yeah,
it's like low level laser light therapy that looks like a giant tanning bed that
you get in.
And I've seen that thing before.
And what does that supposed to do?
It's supposed to somehow or another stimulate that work on your recovery and in
at the cellular level.
Again,
you need to get these,
these Pi personnel in here to,
to explain it in detail,
you guys even have sleep pods,
which I thought it was the craziest thing ever.
It was so like if a fighter just has like an hour to chill,
they can just get in there and recover and relax.
Yeah.
I mean the idea is you come to the performance institute.
They're there and don't get dope and I hear this all the time.
They,
they see the,
the,
the equipment,
the personnel that's available to them.
They see when it's time to unwind that they have a room like this to relax in.
They see you.
They have free use of the cafeteria and custom cook meals.
They don't want to leave the place.
They're there all day long.
Frances and Ghana,
yeah.
Lives has lived there the last six months.
There's a running joke in the office at Francis has constantly walking around
the office in between workouts.
It's like,
Francis,
we got to get you an office here or something like that.
What are you doing?
Yeah,
that's the guy you saw.
I mean the dude move to la,
he saw the place and he moved up and moved everything he had.
I don't think he knew anybody in Las Vegas or not any friends there.
Cause he's,
he's just walking around the office all day long when he's not at the Pi from
France,
from France,
from another country.
He said exactly.
But you know the perfect example of seeing what that place could do for him and
that's available to every single fight or on the roster.
Yeah.
I mean there's nothing like it.
And my prediction is that the UFC is going to be the hub where most people live.
The only thing that's wrong there is the altitude.
That's the only thing that's wrong.
And I know you guys have a hypoxic room where you can stimulate or simulate a
high altitude.
Yeah,
I think 22,000 feet,
but isn't the way you're supposed to do it?
You're supposed to work at sea level,
but sleep at high altitude.
Isn't that how it's supposed to be?
I think that's what it is.
You know what Does Bay,
so 2,500 3000 feet,
so it even isn't really,
that's interesting.
I didn't even know it was that high.
I think it is.
Yep.
I thought it was a little low.
I thought it was like c level cause it's like desert.
No,
no,
no.
It's got a little bit out.
I know Nevada has some good mountain areas though.
Just outside were guys can run and do things like that.
Yeah.
Does,
does the performance institute take people on any tracks or anything like that?
I don't think we've gotten to that level yet.
I got to be a good thing to do.
Right.
Could make to red rocks for runs.
There you go.
It's a good idea.
I mean I just think that if really high level coaches start moving there and
obviously we just lost one of the best Robert Follis,
which is a huge,
huge loss.
And what a great guy and say,
I mean universally nicest guy ever and it was a great deal.
Universally loved,
very few people that are fight coaches that are universally
loved.
And Robert Really was.
But um,
you know,
Vegas has some good coaches,
but I anticipate more and more gyms moving and relocating there and bring
fighters there because I just think high level fighters going to see that place
and go,
how can I recreate this anywhere without fucking millions and millions of
dollars?
I think so.
I mean,
we love to see that happen.
It's,
you know,
a good low cost,
relatively low cost of living area.
Um,
so it's a place that's affordable and uh,
yeah,
I think he spent a little bit of time with the Pii and see what you can do,
what it can do for you as a UFC athlete.
And just when I was,
oh,
go ahead.
I think the other cool thing,
and I know Dunkin French,
he's doctor Dunkin France.
She's our VP of performance,
um,
there and a,
which he explained it a little bit to you about is that not only are we looking
to influence the UFC athlete but also influenced positively and I may the whole
the entire sport and what you're seeing is UFC athletes can come in there and
use it,
but they can also bring along with them training partners,
coaches,
and you know,
we're only seven or eight months into this,
but what we've already seen as,
you know,
training ideas,
proper nutrition,
going back out to these gyms,
not only across the u s but across the world.
So we definitely hope to be a positive influence throughout all of them and May
and,
and really,
really grow the sport.
Yeah,
I saw that with Bobby Green,
Bobby Green who was there,
I brought a couple of his training partners and just on a random day,
Wilson Hayes was there,
Angela Hill was there.
There's quite a few cycles thing ever.
I love,
I'll go over there when I'm in the office multiple times a day just to see who's
in there that day and have,
you know,
that five,
10 minute conversation with a Wilson Hayes that he knows me going forward in the
future and that Jeff's a cool guy and when that medication or supplement
question comes up,
he's talked to me before,
he knows who I am is not afraid to pick up the phone and asked me that question
versus hey,
this golden snitch character,
I don't know,
I don't know who this guy is not going to call him or trust him.
It's a big part of what I do is try to develop those pet trusts.
So thanks to shop or send me back about two and a half years were developed in
that trust and a nickname that doesn't even make sense.
It literally doesn't make sense.
But it's funny.
Um,
is there any other plans to expand or do more things with the institute?
There is.
So we didn't show you this,
but there are other areas upstairs for that very reason.
They thought about hey technology and a couple of years or maybe new machines or
devices that come onto line that we may want.
So there is additional room for expansion there.
I talked to you guys and I talked to Duncan about a tank,
about you guys getting tanks in there.
Uh,
s sensory deprivation tanks.
I think that would be massive.
I know a lot of football teams are using them now and it's starting to spread,
um,
excellent source of magnesium because you're absorbing it through the skin.
But just for relaxation recuperation.
I would be fascinated to see if you guys had those.
Like what kind of results you'd yeah,
I mean it sounded to me,
and I was there when you're talking about it,
that Dunkin was open to it and it was talking about some research,
I think you said Ohio State University is conducting some research on the
benefits of that.
So I know there's tanks in Vegas now.
I know there's a place in Vegas,
so I'm sure whoever runs that tank thing going to reach out to me.
So I want to get you in touch with them.
And how just have you try it.
Just see if,
you know,
just,
just to get a beat on his,
it's a freaky experience and it's really good for your body.
Just everything like in your back.
We'll just sort of just loosen up because you're essentially zero gravity.
You're floating.
It's just,
everything's sort of pops and loosens up and it's amazing.
It's cool.
I want to try it.
I saw yours a little bit ago.
It's little,
little intimidating or scary and looking weird person.
My wife made me move it out of the basement.
I had one in the basement.
She's like,
people come over,
they think you're afraid.
I think I'm a freak.
But um,
the idea behind it I think is pretty sound and I think,
um,
there's a lot of benefits for it,
uh,
for fighters as far as concentrating on technique as well.
I think it's an amazing place to focus on strategy and game plans and movement
and things along those lines.
We can visualize one of the most amazing things with the sport and I,
you know,
coming over to the UFC,
I call myself a fringe fan.
I'm Alec follow it a little bit,
but I'm,
I'm hook,
line and sinker into the sport now.
And the most remarkable thing I find about the sport is the mental game.
It is the most incredible mental game of any athlete in any sport in the world.
When you're walking out into an octagon and facing one of the baddest mixed
martial artists and the planet.
And you know,
I know you've seen a ton of fights over your career,
but I think one thing that,
that I've seen the two and a half years and you may not,
is that progression through fight week.
So when I go out to these events or events or in Vegas,
some there checking day Monday or Tuesday at five week and typically we're,
we're on the road on there every day in the same hotel and watching these guys
and girls eat breakfast.
I'm watching them at the gym prepare,
try to make weight on Friday.
I'm watching them Saturday morning with the prospect of the fight ahead of them.
What an incredible mental journey it is to know that you're about to get into,
you know,
a cage with one of the baddest fighters on the planet.
Then even if you win,
probably come out,
you know,
with a little bit of damage,
I mean everything to,
to fight night,
fight night.
These,
these athletes are in a locker room,
typically with three or four other athletes.
And especially if you're one of the last athletes on that card and one by one
your locker mates are walking out and then coming back in and you see,
you know,
damage on even the ones that win.
And unlike other sports where you get out on the field and you warm up and you
get a little sense of what the atmosphere is like,
these athletes are walking out,
you know,
into the lion's den,
seeing it for the first time and the sensory overwhelming sensory,
uh,
things that are going on when doing that and to be able to control your emotions
and,
you know,
compete against somebody is just absolutely the most incredible thing that,
that I've ever seen.
I'm so amazed at,
and you know,
very few of these fighters and I talked to a lot of them had,
doesn't get to them in some way or form.
Um,
that is uh,
you know,
talk to forest often about that enforce.
It's like it says he equates it to if you'd never jumped out of an airplane the
whole time you're on the way up saying,
what the hell am I doing?
This is crazy.
And then,
you know,
when the bell rings and you start fighting,
then it kind of calms down your back in your,
your kind of zone.
But just what an incredible mental game this is.
And I just have so much respect for our athletes because of what they have to go
through and they're able to do it time and time again and control those
emotions.
You bring up an important point and um,
mental training is something that a lot of athletes have really concentrated on
more over the last few years than I think ever that I could recall.
And a lot of them bringing hypnotists and a lot of bringing in sports
psychologists.
Is there ever been any talk of bringing that to the performance institute?
Yeah.
You know,
I've talked,
I talked briefly with Dunkin about it who has it,
you know,
a ton of resources in the athletic performance field.
And um,
so we've talked briefly about that.
But um,
nobody on the staff,
you know,
currently it's,
it's,
it's kind of a give and take.
Look,
we want to provide all these resources to our athletes,
but we also want them to retain their independence.
I mean,
you don't,
if you notice in the performance institute,
there is no MMA coaches there.
There was no striking wrestling coaches,
Jujitsu coaches,
none of that.
That's for the athlete to bring in because there needs to be some level of
independence.
You don't want to train the entire roster,
you know,
the same way itself.
Exactly.
It's exactly,
it sounds like it was.
I saw early on in my tenure here with the UFC,
I saw one of the most incredible things that,
that I've ever seen.
I've only seen it once,
but I saw a fighter show up,
fight night outside the locker room and basically said,
I don't want to go in.
I don't want to do this at the arena.
Really?
And I mean,
I was just blown away.
And uh,
actually Sean Shelby went up and thought it was awesome.
Had a great conversation with the fighter.
Said,
look,
you're not feeling anything that everybody doesn't feel every single fight or on
the roster fields,
which you're feeling right now.
You're just letting it get the best you.
You know,
you're a Badass fighter.
you've kicked ass before,
you've gotten beat before.
Uh,
you know,
what's the worst going to happen?
You're going to,
you're going to get beat.
You're going to live through this thing.
You're just letting it surface.
Everybody feels what you're feeling.
And for a second,
you know,
the fighter came back a little bit and then boom,
left the arena.
Whoa.
Crazy.
But I think that must enter into the head or the prospect of that,
of every single person,
every single fighter that comes here being,
and I'm sure there's just a little bit of that and the back of the head.
It's just an incredible journey to see them mentally overcome.
Um,
that amount of stress.
The pre fight is incredible.
Why it's so interesting to see a guy like Conor who silver laxed in there.
It's kind of weird,
you know,
like when he does that rubber arms strut loose walking
around the cage,
he's Kinda like letting you know how he is dealing with this better than you
are.
You know,
the one fighter that,
uh,
cause I paid really close attention after having seen that early pay really
close attention just to see that fight or on the walkout,
like to sit in a pretty close to the cage and just look at that fighter's eyes.
And I,
I tend to see a little bit of nervousness and fear and,
and everyone,
I think it's probably healthy.
One person that sticks out that I looked at and I saw nothing in this dude's
face.
I saw like a little smirk,
like he was so happy to be in there and it's the first time I've seen this guy
fight and that's just engaging.
When he fought Michael Johnson,
I remember look,
and he walked in first and I was sitting on one side and he's on the other side
of the cage and looking in his eyes and I had never seen him fight before.
And I'm like,
who is this guy?
He looks like he's happy to be in there like this is,
you know,
some parties at.
And that fight was incredible.
Well,
he's crazy,
wasn't it?
He's legitimately crazy.
He said that getting knocked out by Eddie Alvarez,
the greatest thing that ever happened to him in his life,
he's a different breed.
Yeah,
well he's got a mindset and that mindset is,
um,
coming to go to war.
And he said it when he got signed,
he said,
uh,
over the next couple of years,
I'm going to get knocked out.
Someone's going to knock me out.
He goes,
but I'm going to knock a lot of people out and I'm going to break people,
you know?
And the only way to stop me to shut me off.
And he goes,
I'm human.
I can be shut off.
I want to watch that guy fight every time.
Every time.
Yeah.
I mean that's an incredible mindset.
And I don't know if you can teach that.
I think a lot of people say you can't teach mental strength.
And I don't,
I think that's horseshit.
I think you could teach everything.
I think the mind can be,
can be trained.
I mean this is what they do in bootcamp,
right?
I mean,
and it works to varying degrees of success.
I think the mind can be trained.
It's just a matter of what's your baseline?
Where are you coming in at?
Are you a total scaredy cat or are you a pretty stoic,
rugged dude to begin with?
And what can they do?
And maybe,
maybe you're too stuck.
Maybe you're,
you're too nonemotional and you're to non vulnerable and you,
you're delusional and your perceptions.
It's amazing seeing the different ways that different athletes deal with it.
So Saturday night,
I give you a perfect example.
So fight night,
um,
you know,
you saw it as the one doing the testing.
A lot of times fight night.
There's not a lot going on in my world on there to put out fires in case
something does go on.
I like to watch the fights close.
Um,
just to see those things we're talking about here.
So,
but occasionally I'll,
I'll pop in backstage just to make sure everything's going good.
So I walked back there before the Holly Cyborg fight and so Holly was out in the
Hallway,
um,
getting ready to do that long walk for the championship bout and she was there
for probably about 10 minutes.
Camera's getting ready and she was doing that.
Holly pacing back and forth and her hands together firing herself up when she
did it for a good 10 minutes back there.
And then you see,
once she gets in the cage,
she was the first one in their pacing back and forth for 10 minutes.
Right.
Hitting the hands together every between,
every single round she'd get off that stool back and forth,
pacing,
hitting the hands together.
That's the way she fired herself up.
She Carlos bars,
we'll walk out.
She walks out with like zero emotion on her face.
Like,
is this girl ready to go?
She gets in the cage,
walks over one side and just stands there and doesn't bounce around at all that
you know,
hey,
you see both,
both of them,
you know,
can have success doing that way.
Dealing with,
you know,
it's amazing to see it.
There's a groove that they get into,
they get,
they get in the comfort zone.
They just like,
this is what I do.
Every time I've compete and everybody's is different.
And you know,
some people don't like to bounce around.
But I remember when Holly did that during the Ronda Rousey fight.
I remember how I was looking at her.
I'm like,
this girl's got some legs.
I was like,
I'd seen her fight before and I knew that she was and some stamina.
I mean,
between the 10 minutes backstage before she walked out the five minutes after
she was in the cage and Cyborg is walking out the 10 or 15 seconds between every
round.
She probably,
you know,
ran a couple of miles.
Yeah.
The equivalent of a couple extra rounds and she was,
yeah,
she was as fresh at the end of,
she wasn't beginning tremendous cardio.
And that girl,
well,
Jackson's camp,
you know that Michael,
uh,
excuse me,
the uh,
Greg Jackson and Mike Winkeljohn camp,
they,
they spend a lot of time working on endurance training,
strength and conditioning and they do a lot of hill running.
You know,
they have this famous mountain that they run that they all do.
And just Holly's been known for not just her cardio,
but like I said in the Rhonda fight,
her legs,
the way she can move.
Yeah.
I,
that's one of the things that I thought was going to be a big problem with her.
With Rhonda.
It was like Ron has got to catch her,
like the way she's bouncing and moving.
I don't think Rhonda can move like that.
I'm like watching her bouncing move and that crazy kickboxing style that she'd
had for all those years or ability to do back flips and stuff.
She's really athletic.
She's a different different level of athlete.
Yup.
Yeah.
But cyberark is just too big,
too big,
too skillful to tough show.
She showed a lot.
She showed a lot of skill in that fight.
I was,
you know,
her previous UFC fights,
she was just kind of coming at people and mall.
I thought she was really skillfulness five very,
very patient too.
You know.
I mean a lot of people want to say that she's just a brute,
but she's not like she's,
she's,
she knows what her skills arm,
which is big power and excellent Moy Tai.
But she also administered that power.
The way she delivered it was very skillful,
very,
very methodical,
very professional.
And that was a workman like really was.
It was initially I talked to somebody in our camp and they wanted to see a
little bit more of that brute power come right out.
And they thought she was holding back a little bit.
Maybe a little too skillful,
but I thought it was great.
While they want her to stop,
you know,
a Holly,
but you running the risky,
getting head kicked.
Sure.
You know,
you gotta be real careful with Holly Holly pull stuff out of our ass.
like he sat in the drain and Germane to random he phi,
he saw it and obviously the Rhonda fight,
she needs very sneaky.
She knows how to,
especially that left high kick man.
She knows how to sneak down such a great,
that was a great fight.
Love watching that fight.
Yeah.
The women's MMA talent level has risen and risen and it,
it is,
I mean,
I remember when it first came on the scene and Rhonda was the champ and she was
just kind of roll in these girls who really didn't belong in the ring with her.
It how it has and you know,
interesting.
Bringing back to the performance institute,
you know,
talk with guys a lot over there that what they're finding out is you need to
train a female athlete in a much different manner than you train a male athlete.
Um,
you know,
you see a lot of times when female athletes cut weight,
difficult difficulties,
they have cutting that way because of,
you know,
menstrual cycles potentially.
And you also see in a lot of cases,
a rebound effect where a female will fight,
get down to weight,
fight,
and then bounce way back up and just lose the ability,
the body's ability to regulate where there'll be cutting down on calories
working out like crazy and they're still putting on weight.
Um,
so I mean,
I think that's something that you'll see the performance institute doing is try
to,
you know,
figure out and then knowledgeability disseminate information about how to train
the female athlete that they may need a little bit more time off and recovery
between fights than a male athlete will.
But one thing I say,
time and time again is every time we have a female fight,
they come to fight.
And you often see cards that are,
you know,
kind of lagging a little bit and you look down on the list,
okay,
there comes a female fight,
boom turns the car and ride around because you know,
inevitably they,
they give ultimate maximum effort in there.
That's at least what I see.
There's a lot of that.
Well,
there's the,
the t,
excuse me,
the talent level is rising.
They're very hungry and they're,
they're looking to be that next person.
They realize like,
look,
Ronda Rousey is gone.
No one has really filled her place.
I mean there's some very popular fighters,
you know,
like a rose Nama units obviously now is going to be one of the most popular
fighters after the knock out of you on e and j check cyborgs,
obviously very popular,
but there's plenty of room for more and they realize that,
look,
this is the time to go for it.
And I just think that,
you know,
the women that get involved in fighting in the first place,
it's not,
there's a lot of men that get involved in fighting.
They're not going to fight after awhile.
But women that get involved in fighting,
they tend to be crazy,
like in,
in a good way.
You know,
like these are wild women,
you know,
like cats in Ghana type characters.
You know,
they're just wild.
And like when you watch them fight,
I mean,
you,
you're going to see some chaos.
I mean,
they're,
they're not going to be playing it safe.
They're going to be going for it.
Yeah.
I love that about him.
Now,
cat is an interesting example because she was telling me the exact same thing
that you were saying that with a lot of women,
their body responds very poorly to the weight cut and then immediately wants to
gain weight afterwards.
Yep.
Do you think that that's a,
some sort of a,
uh,
like an evolutionary feature because of their,
the fact that they carry babies and Mckinney they need fat so thereby freaks
out?
I've definitely thought that.
Sure.
Or some sort of a response.
Like your body's like,
Hey,
I don't know what this crazy person is doing but we've got to put some fat on.
Absolutely.
And that's,
you know,
that's something we're again going back to the performance institute that
they're their,
their dive in deep into and Clinton Wattenberg especially on the nutrition side
that,
you know,
seeing those endocrine profiles after a fight,
what can you do both and cutting back and training and you know,
through your,
through your diet to help control and regulate that.
And Kat was telling me about a program that you guys were just,
you were just mentioning briefly in San Diego where they're using some sort of
magnetic frequencies on fighters that have had brain injuries.
Like what,
what is this?
Yeah,
what was something that the doctor Dunkin French kind of brought into the mix
here?
Um,
so previous come into UFC,
he was director of sports performance at University of Notre Dame in south bend,
Indiana.
And they were looking into,
um,
you know,
traumatic brain injury and football and possible therapy.
Um,
and they came across a clinic in San Diego that was using this therapy and FDA
approved device.
It's basically low level magnet therapy,
um,
in conjunction with that,
they do some EKG or reading of the electrical waves in the brain.
And you know,
uh,
initially we're finding that this therapy was bringing some of those readings
back together and,
uh,
I think very early,
um,
in,
in the process of figuring out whether this can really work or not.
But you know,
certainly with the UFC wants to be as ahead of the curve in terms of potential
therapies out there for,
um,
you know,
for treating the brain.
Um,
and so,
uh,
yeah,
cat's been going there for a while and um,
you know,
as I said,
she says she's experienced some positive results.
Yeah.
She's,
she told me she got some outstanding results.
And what's interesting is there's been a ton of research and studies done on
transdermal stimulation,
all these different,
uh,
ways to increase the,
the brain's ability to learn.
And um,
there was a radio lab podcast on this,
I think it was called something nine volts,
if you could find at nine volts something or another.
But it basically detailed how they use this for a sniper simulation.
And what they did is they took this woman who was a reporter,
um,
they put her through this sniper simulation games,
like a video game.
She scored poorly and then,
yeah,
nine volt Nirvana.
Thank you Jamie.
And so then they attach these electrodes to various areas of her head and
stimulated her brain with a small charge.
And she went through the exact same thing and she said it felt like the 20
minutes went by in two minutes and her,
her score was perfect.
And this is being echoed throughout like many different people that have done
tests on these very,
and there's a lot of like home hacking where people are literally going to radio
lab and making their own setups.
But I'm curious to
see if the UFC has looked into some of these things.
Like some like maybe perhaps there's a way you could stimulate the body's
ability to learn certain techniques or like carve pathways by stimulating areas
of the brain.
Yeah,
man.
Another great reason for you to get Duncan in here because he can talk real
knowledge to be about this therapy.
He told me when at the University of Notre Dame,
you know,
they'd have,
they've had football players,
it would,
you know,
have migraine headaches for long periods of time than under what this therapy in
a matter of weeks they were,
they went away.
Um,
when Donna and I visited the facility down in San Diego,
they talked about,
uh,
employees of the facility,
bringing in their kids,
a kids that had some levels of autism that after this therapy were more engaging
with people.
They also talked about kids that had tests or finals coming up the day after
where they go in for this therapy the night before and get their test scores
were improving as a result.
Um,
it was a lot of,
they deal with a lot of special forces soldiers down in the San Diego area that
have had traumatic brain injuries because of,
you know,
ids and a,
I've seen some success there.
So I mean,
I think some real exciting potential there that again,
you know,
the UFC wants to be at the forefront of and you know,
be the first to,
you know,
to suggest some of these things for our athletes and you know,
potentially even looking,
getting some of these devices at the Pi,
um,
and be able to treat some of our athletes there.
Yeah,
that would be amazing.
And I think that we're in an interesting time now where,
because so much research is being put on CTE and traumatic brain injuries that
were,
we're looking at potential ways to mitigate those problems and maybe even rehab
some of the issues that fighters of having.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
one thing we didn't show you and your tour is a,
we now make part of the onboarding process at the Pi,
the c three logic testing,
which is this,
you know,
25,
30 minute neurocognitive tests that came out of the Cleveland Clinic brain study
and it's an iPad based tests.
Um,
it's a mix of memory,
shape,
recognition,
balance.
You actually,
you know,
put the pad on your,
onto a belt,
you stand on this unstable surface and close your eyes and it basically gives
you measurements or readings after 25 or 30 minutes.
And then,
you know,
over time you can compare those readings.
If they're declining,
maybe it's time to take a little bit of time off from,
from training and fighting.
Um,
if they're staying stable,
then you know,
maybe you know,
you're doing all right.
The California Athletic Commission requires that for all fights.
So all fighters in any card in California,
the Wednesday or Thursday before the fight goes through the c three logic
testing,
all of it's uploaded to a cloud.
So you don't,
after a period of a couple of years,
um,
a fighter can have access to some real objective data on,
you know,
with the neuro cognitive capabilities are looking like that would be a great way
to find out.
I mean maybe one of the only ways to find out without fighter to declaw
disclosing
it,
whether or not a fighter has been knocked out in camp because that,
that's a common occurrence that fighters get knocked out in camp and hard
sparring and then a week,
two weeks later have to fight and their ability to take a shot is gone.
Sure.
Yeah.
It's interesting,
you know,
often asked about that and comparing it to other sports leagues.
And the one thing I will say,
you know,
with Nma now this is excluding things are going on in the gym,
but in a fight that's regulated by the Athletic Commission,
I think.
And then may have some of the most conservative return to play policy.
I know it does have any sport we're in.
If you're an NFL quarterback and you get knocked out on a Sunday,
yeah,
you're in a concussion protocol,
but they're trying to get you back plan probably the next Sunday or the Sunday
thereafter,
which is crazy.
The big concussion and MMA as you know,
there's like a 45 60 mandatory 45 days,
no activities,
60 days before you fight.
I mean,
we've seen suspensions out to six months,
mandatory medical suspension.
So,
and some of them I think are very warranted.
I mean there's some brutal brutal knockouts where like Alistair Overeem and
Francis and [inaudible] like,
I don't want to see Alistair fight next month.
You know what I mean?
I don't,
and here's a question about a guy like Allister,
Allister,
we looked it up one day on a podcast has been stopped or knocked out somewhere
in the neighborhood of 13 times in MMA and then three times more in kickboxing.
What,
what's the number where you like,
that's enough.
Yeah,
I don't know the answer to that.
Um,
I know you talked with Allister and Scott and his wits about him.
That's what's crazy.
Allister doesn't even seem remotely punching.
I mean,
he is not only that,
he doesn't seem deterred,
like it's crazy.
Like he gets knocked out and he's like,
well,
we go back to the drawing board and uh,
we'll be better next time.
Like,
I think it's an unknown now.
But you also look at,
you know,
the UFC has been the largest contributor to the Cleveland Clinic fight or brain
health study.
So we,
you know,
made I think multimillion dollar commitment.
Uh,
we've upped it once.
Um,
so yeah,
we're looking to invest resources into finding out what those answers are
definitely.
And be at the forefront of any innovative therapies that are out there.
Innovative,
you know,
testing.
It's out there.
We want to be at the front.
Well,
the,
the issue with CTE is that you really can't test for it until after a fighters
dead.
Correct.
But haven't they recently figured out a way to test people while they're alive?
Yeah,
I'm,
I've read some of that.
I've also read that scientists arguing that,
that,
you know,
that's fine and that's not right.
So I don't know where we're at on that.
Yeah.
Because boy,
it just seems like
I don't want to end.
It also affects people differently,
right.
Depending upon what genes they have,
some people are more predisposed to CTE.
Yeah.
And that's,
that's my understanding of it.
Again,
a lot of unknowns.
But um,
you know,
I think that the UFC has shown a dedication to,
contributing to areas where we can find out some of those answers.
Yeah.
Um,
like I know that you guys recently had mark come to Vegas because Mark Han had
talked about suffering damage from fights in the UFC.
Said,
you know what?
We can just hear him say that we're going to pull them off this card.
And he was furious and they said,
look like we love you,
don't get it wrong,
but we want you,
we want you to be safe.
And you say that you're slurring your words.
And then he changed it and said,
well,
it's after a few drinks and then then went,
okay,
well come by and let's give you the full gamut of tests as exact what happened.
And we're always going to act out of an abundance of caution.
And in a scenario like that.
And so now he's back on the roster and back with a fight scheduled.
He's fighting in Perth and in February.
So when a guy says something like that,
you just Kinda have to,
you have,
when a guy says,
I'm slurring my words,
I've been,
I've taken too much punishment.
Like,
okay,
we've got a red flag here.
You have to,
right?
Yeah,
absolutely.
I mean,
that happened.
I looked back to on a few member when Kane was gonna fight a,
at the end of last year asking,
you came out a week or two previous saying,
man,
I'm in so much pain from this back issue.
I'm having to use medical marijuana CBD leading up to this fight.
The only way I can train,
I'm going to have this surgery directly after the fight.
Um,
it was actually a Nevada commission that saw this and said,
wait a second,
if you're really in that much pain,
like we can't with good conscience,
I'm license you to fight.
And sure enough they didn't do that and ended up having the surgery and uh,
hopefully as back pretty soon.
But it's been like a year now.
Yeah.
He's a guy that is almost too tough for his body or maybe is to tougher his
body.
If you watch cane fight,
particularly early in his career when he's in his prime,
you just couldn't believe the amount of endurance that a 240 pound man can have.
The,
the just the pace that he would put on guys and you'd see them just drowning in
that pace.
But the only way you get,
I mean you have to have some physical gifts cardiovascularly and I think Kane
will admit that he has some,
uh,
some natural cardio,
but unbelievable work ethic and mental toughness.
And that mental toughness also makes you push through injuries and pushing
through injuries is how injuries become chronic.
And that's how injuries become unmanageable and require surgery.
I mean you would know I,
I'm,
I was an athlete and went through my share of injuries,
but you know,
I played basketball and ran track and in those sports,
you know,
depending on your injury you can control,
I think your exposure and protect your body.
I mean,
how do you do that in fighting?
You can't,
you can't,
you can't prevent certain positions that your lot you're going to be in.
And if you're not completely healthy,
you're going to be probably exposed from the only thing you could drill.
I mean,
if you really injured and you have a good opponent or a good training partner,
you can drill on certain things and say,
hey man,
you just can't touch my shoulder but there's no way you can spar.
And there's no way you could really prepare for a fight without really hard
training and hard training with,
with injuries is virtually impossible.
I mean,
we,
with some injuries,
you know what I mean of them,
you can work around.
This is ways to figure a way around things.
And that's one of the things that I've found was really interesting also about
the UFC performances too,
does there's a lot of different things that you guys have devised or have,
you know,
you've guys are brought in and implemented that other people have devised to
help people with injuries that are trying to still train hard.
Like that gravity treadmill thing that's in our,
in our altitude chamber.
So you strap that around you and you're getting not,
you know,
I don't know what the ratio is too.
You know,
if you're true weight to what type of stress you're putting on your body,
but it's much less and going out and run it on a regular treadmill or on the
street now outside the underwater treadmill,
which you saw.
So that was weird.
Angela Hill was on that and I was like,
what's that like?
She's like,
it's weird.
Yeah,
it's like,
it just seems like the floor is moving.
You've got to check,
keep up with it.
Basically it's a rising floor.
So you rise up to the top,
you step on it,
and then it drops down and it works like a regular treadmill because you're,
but because you're under water,
you're putting less stress on obviously your lower extremities.
And if you notice also there's cameras underwater with a TV screen right in
front of,
of the,
uh,
the person using them.
The idea there is if you have an ankle injury or a knee injury,
you could take a look at how your foot's coming down and are you favor in it and
what's your,
your gate looking like?
So cool piece of equipment.
Connor was using that quite a bit and in the run up to,
uh,
to Floyd,
he put a lot of stuff out there on social media on that thing.
I think you liked it.
Yeah.
Well he's got a bum knee,
right?
He's got a niece that has had a,
he's had some issues with in the past.
There it is.
That's done.
There's a Dunkin French off there to the right,
I think.
Just drops you down and then you run in that thing.
Yup.
Yeah.
Oh Man,
I'm not 100% sold on that to be honest with it.
That's why I should come out and get it.
Get on it.
Yeah.
I mean I'm sure it's difficult,
but I think that like actually carrying your weight and running on hills is a
way to go probably now look,
if you're coming off an ACL surgery,
right,
and you know you're taking baby steps to get back to running,
it's probably there.
Otherwise,
if you're healthy and you know,
training for a fight coming up in a couple of weeks,
I don't know if that's necessarily,
that's he's good equipment for you.
He's a guy that I'm puzzled by.
Conor.
Obviously I'm a gigantic fan,
but man,
his cardio,
it seems like there's a thing there.
There's something there.
Whether it's the style that he fights,
the explosive sprinting style that he fights,
it's unsustainable,
you know,
or whether or not there seems to be some sort of an issue that that needs to be
addressed.
Some much more radical approach to a strength and conditioning.
And I would love to see the guys that performance institute try to tackle that
and try to figure out,
I mean,
I'm sure they've run vo two Max is on them and,
but he gets it.
He did most of his camp there,
but you know,
he had his own team around him that was kind of directing him.
Um,
but in his defense,
this was a very quick camp.
You're getting ready for a 12 round fight with the greatest fighter of all time
in boxing.
Jesus Christ.
It's like six or seven weeks.
I think Floyd knew what he was doing.
I tell you one of the incredible things about that and there wasn't a lot said
about it going back to kind my world anti-doping world.
So Floyd does this for all his fights.
He basically hires you sought to do testing.
Um,
it's not,
you know,
it's not the same as the UFC program where you're subject to testing year round
in boxing.
Once the fight has made you saw to then comes in and does collecting.
So it depends on how far out the fight was made.
But Conor and Floyd sign that contract,
was it seven weeks out?
Maybe they were each tested 16 times and that seven weeks.
And I guarantee you they are the two most tested athletes and that pure short
period of time ever in the history of anti-doping.
So not only was it a incredibly cool event,
but I think incredibly clean,
cool and clean for the fans and know that you know how out of the way those two
guys went to ensure that that fight was fair and clean.
That is amazing enough credit for that.
It's too bad.
There's not too performance institutes or you could have one right next to each
other.
We're opponents could train at very,
you know,
like you could film things at the performance institute in a,
at a level.
Um,
Forrest Griffin was showing me how the octagon is set up with 360 degree cameras
and you could literally film and then rotate angles up down.
You can,
you can move around and show,
oh,
when you're throwing this punch,
your back foot is coming off the ground.
When you're leaning to your left,
you're dropping your hand.
It's like the John Madden telestrator do stop action and draw on that huge big
screen next to the octagon around exactly what Floyd was shown.
Or excuse me,
when,
um,
uh,
forest was showing me how you can move it around.
I was like,
this is insane.
Like this.
What a tool this is for technique development.
It really,
and I think we're at the infancy of,
of these coaches coming in and figuring out how they can use these things he had
sent that they can benefit their funders.
I mean that,
there it is right there.
Yeah.
This thing,
oh,
there's my tour.
Well,
did somebody put that up on these fucking on already?
They put it up.
Um,
I didn't put this,
Oh yeah.
Put It on my Instagram stories,
but I didn't put it on Youtube.
Somebody put it on youtube here.
So what what force was showing me was how they can pause it and slow mo and back
it up and then change angles and that all the fighters sparring sessions or
filmed their film from an overhead,
their film from the sides.
And there's cameras all around the octagon.
I mean it's just what a facility man.
Yeah.
I mean I really think we talked about this.
This is bringing the sport to a whole new level.
Yeah.
Well Frances is going to be your first test tube sorta child.
You know you talked about,
wouldn't it be nice to have two opponents working side by side?
The Pi has that capability.
I mean as you saw it,
it's set up specifically.
So you have certain things downstairs and certain things upstairs so you'd have
to schedule it.
So Steve Bay says,
Hey man,
I want to come out and use this.
It is,
it is open to Steve Bay.
We could schedule it.
So Steve Bay's downstairs doing a strength and conditioning and while Francis
was upstairs,
it's a lot of what forest does force,
you know,
it could be the intermediary to make sure Francis goes out one door,
Steepbank comes in another never run into themselves.
But that definitely has taken them and they are there.
But yeah,
but what I would,
if I was tpa,
I would not want to be doing strength conditioning and then in between sets,
just like have your ear and you hear Coppola.
Francis is hitting the heavy bag and scaring everybody.
You your style.
You tried that,
that punch machine.
Yeah,
he's got the world record punch on that.
There's a,
what it is is like a for folks,
it's a pad.
It's adjustable,
it moves up and down and you punch it.
And not only did he break the world record,
he broke it by several thousand pounds per square inch.
Yeah.
I think his reading,
and I don't know what the reading is,
was 129,000 something and yeah,
he's terrified.
It is.
You hit it a couple times,
man.
I thought you were hitting pretty hard.
Now,
what did you register?
Like a 35 or 40,000?
I got 46 is my hardest one to,
I hurt my hand.
He kind of put gloves on to do that too.
I would imagine that being wrapped up and that's an argument that I've had many
times when it comes to MMA in general.
I like how you can angle it so you can throw an uppercut as well.
Um,
that's an argument that I've had.
for MMA in general,
I think it's weird that we,
uh,
are allowed to elbow with no pad knee with no pad kick with no pad on the Shin,
but the knuckles are protected.
And I think that it really probably allows people to deliver more damage with
the knuckles padded.
I don't think padded knuckles helps your opponent as much as it helps you.
And especially risk protection.
Like when I was trying to punch that thing with just my bare hands,
um,
which is stupid,
especially when you haven't warmed up.
Right.
But you're,
you realize like your,
your wrist moves around,
he's slamming of that thing and if you're hitting it hard,
your wrist moves around.
Well that's the case.
When you're punching a person to like,
you have to be much more precise with where you're targeting and what you're
hitting.
You can't hit foreheads and elbows,
you'll break your hand like very easily.
And I wonder,
it's just,
it seems barbaric to people to,
to fight bare knuckle,
which to me is kind of crazy cause you're kicking,
like you're,
you're shinning people in the head like I don't understand.
Like we have this weird sort of childish view of like what should and shouldn't
be.
Legal elbows are some of the hardest.
I mean,
you can just do that with an owl and it doesn't hurt at all.
You know,
your knees,
your shins,
those guys that,
uh,
spar Muay Thai for a years and years,
their shins develop calcification all over the top where they can kick baseball
bats.
Like there's trees.
Yeah,
it's,
there's a great one.
Have a bull cow,
uh,
kicking a banana tree just going cray.
And he's one of the greatest tie fighters of all time,
but he's,
he's chopping at this banana tree and cuts it in half and you're like,
Jesus,
like how is it okay that that guy can kick someone in the face with that?
But you have to have pads here.
He was right here.
Like,
give me some volume on this.
Okay.
Waken a fucking tree.
I
is not doing that with his bare knuckle will tell you that.
That's insane.
Fucking hit in the face with that.
But see the difference like that's hard bone.
Yeah,
no padding.
Why do you have to have padding on your knuckles but you don't have to have it
on your shins and your knees and your elbows.
That seems to me to be a silly way of approaching everything.
Yeah.
I mean maybe we could pat up everything,
but then people get mad.
Yeah.
Like we're posing for the sport.
I think you go the other way.
I think you don't pat up anything.
I think you pat up your Dick and that's it.
That's what I think.
Pat Up your teeth pad up your Dick.
Let her rip.
I really think they should fight bare knuckle.
I just don't think it makes any sense whatsoever.
Especially considering the fact that I poke.
So one of the major considerations,
right.
You're not going to mitigate that with those gloves.
You're just,
you know,
unless they develop some sort of a new designed where the gloves are much more
curled in.
Yeah.
Um,
there,
there's the,
the I pokes or it was going to be an issue.
It would be the exact same issue if you had bare knuckle.
Well,
yeah,
I mean now you can take away with a new unified rules,
which,
uh,
ironically enough aren't unified.
Yeah.
I'm so we go from commission to commission and you know,
flight or what have to inform them.
Fight week,
Hey,
what are the rules here that's so unfair to these fighters that in our training
and developing that instinct to some of these rules.
But anyway,
the new unified rules which aren't unified,
um,
anybody who's extending the fingers at the referee has to warn them first.
But they continue to do that.
A point can be taken away.
I think they should take a point.
Every time I got gets poked in the eye and my,
my thought process is even if it's unintentional,
the damage has been done.
And if,
uh,
if you could see it on the replay,
legitimate,
I poke and you see the guy and wincing,
like,
which we've seen many,
many times that guys compromised and I think that it's only fair that a point be
taken away even if it was unintentional.
What's like,
you know,
kicking or needing a down fighter too,
that you know,
you have to show intent to take a point away.
Right.
How is the referee going to get in the head of a fighter to say whether or not
that was intentional?
Ride it,
it should almost be I think that if it's done,
uh,
points taken away,
I agree.
Remove the intent from it because the damage is already done at that point.
Yeah.
It doesn't matter whether or not this intentional,
I mean,
we're not putting the blame on the fighter.
It just,
it happened.
It's one of the unfortunate things,
but the fighter that got hit is the one who suffers the consequences of it.
There's no way it should be an even exchange like,
oh,
I'm sorry,
I accidentally need your eye socket it.
Yeah,
yeah,
no,
no point taken.
And now you can't go on that.
That to me sounds,
I think there's room to,
to,
to alter the rules and I mean I,
I've,
I'm beating a dead horse with my bare knuckle thing because I've been talking
about that for years because I just think people have a
greatly exaggerated perception of the effectiveness of punching people in the
face.
And I think that greatly exaggerated perception is due to the fact that they
wrap their hands,
you wrap up your wrists and your,
your wrist and your hand becomes a cast where it's not bending at all.
I mean you get deep in there with athletic tape and Gauze and they cover the
knuckles and everything gets good at it and you could just fucking blast
something with that.
But when you just have just your hands,
it feels very delicate.
I always tell people you should punch the bag occasionally at least bare
knuckle,
just go and punch the bag and you realize you can't really hit nearly as hard.
It's just,
I just think that we have like you can't take the shit out of your ankles.
Right?
Right.
I mean we've stopped fighters from walking into the octagon with fully tie,
taped up ankles,
you know,
pull some commissions,
allow light tape and then a neoprene sleeve over it.
Others say no,
nothing.
Again,
the uniformity is again,
you know what to talk about uniform,
but he kind of bringing it back to the anti-doping world.
This is a big point of contention I have with athletic commissions.
Really,
really frustrated.
And that's the marijuana rules.
So you're talking my language is,
you have to see,
I thought.
So the UFC follows the water rules world antidoping agency kind of sets the
world standard.
They have scientists that study these drugs and determine a is something
performance enhancing B,
is it a health and safety issue?
And over the last couple of years they rise.
They raised the marijuana threshold used to be 15 nanograms per milliliter.
Now must succeed 150 nanograms per milliliter,
which everybody metabolizes differently.
But you know from scientists that I've talked about,
the ingestion of marijuana or THC,
the psychoactive ingredient has to be pretty damn close to that collection in
order to exceed 150 nanograms per milliliter,
which means you literally almost have to be high the day pretty much.
So if an athlete just takes a day or two off,
their most light suggests longer than that,
just because you never know how different people metabolize things differently
as you're cutting weight,
whether you're releasing some from your fat cells.
I don't know,
I would suggest you know,
several weeks,
but the reality is it could be a lot closer than that.
What we're running into several athletic commissions,
Texas being one New York being another,
we had probably the most extreme one last month in Michigan that have lower
thresholds.
Um,
Texas and New York have 35 or 50 Michigan where we just came from has a no
tolerance policy for marijuana.
So any measurable amount of THC would cause a positive test.
And we lobbied them hard in anticipation of our event.
They're saying,
do you realize what this means?
I mean,
a fighter could walk through a cloud of secondhand smoke,
you know,
on the way to weigh in or a fight and it's going to show up a measurable amount
and you're going to fight or could win a championship on that and you're going
to take that championship away and overturn the,
when we hadn't,
Texas a couple wins overturned for a threshold,
which I think we're a little bit of,
I think 35,
it's your 35 or 50 was there,
but there were slightly over that.
Well under the,
you know,
established world standard and man,
I think these athletic commissions got to take a serious look at bringing those
into uniformity.
You have,
you know,
in the u s should have certain states now where it's legal medically and
recreationally,
but you know,
arguably federally,
um,
still illegal.
But you have some countries where it's completely legal and you have doctors
prescribing this for,
you know,
pain control or stress or anxiety and you know,
uh,
commission like Michigan,
one of those fighters from one of those countries that is completely legally
doing it under the care of a doctor.
And in lieu of doing a synthetic drug,
like an opioid or a Xanax or something like that,
common sense would tell you it's much healthier and safer to do that.
Um,
you know,
you're setting up this barrier that,
could negatively affect a fighter's career if they have any discernible amount
in their system.
And,
um,
you know,
not only from the unified rules but from,
from an anti-doping marijuana's perspective to these commissions have got to
come together and you know,
realize what the right thing to do is and stop,
you know,
and a lot of instances stop governing or policing just because you can.
Um,
we ran into that with the whole Cortney Casey thing and in Texas,
I don't know if you familiar with that.
Yeah.
Just explain what happened.
So Courtney fought in Texas,
had a great win against Jessica Aguilar.
I think it was probably the defining moment of her career.
She looked really,
really good.
Um,
a couple of weeks later,
I was actually at our event and Stockholm,
Sweden,
I mean,
it was vividly on a Friday night.
Um,
I got a call from her and I can't even understand what she's saying.
She's just crying uncontrollably.
Saint Jeff,
you know,
what is going on?
I didn't even understand what it happens.
It slows down what happened.
So there's stuff on the Internet about me testing positive.
I've,
I've never even thought about using a prohibited substance.
I'm super careful about what I use.
So I said,
okay,
let me check into it.
And so I called a guy on the Texas commission.
I said,
hey,
what's going on?
You know,
with this Cortney Casey thing?
And he tells me,
yeah,
she,
she tested positive.
We just announced it and I said,
for what she said,
or her tee ratio was elevated.
It was over a four to one.
And,
you know,
knowing with that measurement means,
um,
I said,
explain what it means.
Yeah.
So tee tee his testosterone,
he is Epi,
testosterone and every human being male and female have on average a one to one
ratio naturally occurring in them.
And if you take anabolic steroids,
it can have a tendency to raise that ratio,
um,
where the t becomes higher than the e.
Um,
however,
what anti-doping has found out and evolved into the last few years that
especially mildly elevated ratios.
Sometime there are natural reasons for that happening,
especially in females,
especially females on birth control,
which is illegal medication.
And so what you do now in anti-doping,
when you have an elevated tee ratio,
you go to a backup test.
That backhoe test is called an isotope ratio mass spectrometry or earns test.
And that reads the carbon atom in the testosterone in a sample to determine
whether or not it's plant based,
which would mean a synthetic or it's naturally occurring because testosterone is
synthesized through wild yams.
Correct?
Right.
So that's how they find out.
Let's plant based.
That's correct.
So Texas tells me,
hey,
her ratio was a little bit higher than afforded one.
That means she's positive and they say,
they tell me,
we're just following your guys' rules.
And I tell the guy that's not our rules.
I go,
you just announced a positive test for this girl.
And Hey,
you know,
maybe she did do something,
I don't know,
but you're supposed to run the backup test for this.
And it was basically told me,
well it was a Friday.
He goes,
well,
our office is closed Monday,
we'll get back to you on Tuesday.
And really thereafter it was radio silence.
So we were working with Courtney,
worked with Usada closely and you saw a stepped in and said,
absolutely,
that is wrong.
We're going to go back and look at her biological profile and we'll share that
with Texas.
We'll take a look at these tee readings over the time of the samples that she
submitted.
Sure enough,
most of the samples were mildly elevated.
And sure enough,
you saw to do the right thing.
And they went and did that backup testing.
And every time they did it she was negative.
So they reached out to Texas,
said,
hey,
we'll share this information with you.
And,
and,
and our historical records,
his girl does have a naturally occurring,
mildly elevated t ratio.
Uh,
then went through a several week process of figuring out,
hey,
is there some of that sample remaining?
Because if there is Texas,
you have an obligation to go ahead and do this backup testing on it.
Took them a number of weeks were poor.
Courtney was in limbo and I'm finally,
Dana put him on blast,
basically said Texas commission,
you know,
get your shit together.
We're not coming back there.
Um,
and we got ahold of that remaining sample or be sampled,
had it tested at a lot of laboratory and was negative on the IRM mass that
putting someone on blast works.
No,
it's,
it's an ego thing.
Like people are bitching at you,
you're going to succumb to that.
But yeah,
sometimes that's what it takes to get someone to do the right thing.
It does.
So,
so this poor girl is living with the fact that she's labeled as a cheater for
two to three months,
talked about she's still will be.
Yeah.
Well,
it's one of those things like once someone says you're a steroid cheater,
we all,
the way she talked to,
I mean she lived,
she lives on Maui,
so small community.
She talked about going to the store and people pointing at her talking bad about
her.
She talked about she,
she's a coach and a gym.
They're coaches,
kids about parents,
you know,
not one her to coach their kids when this was inland labor,
how many of those people heard that she was exonerated headlines on page one for
tat retraction on the back page.
Right.
And nobody pays attention to that shit.
And you know her performance and she fought Detroit,
right?
Yes.
It was not a great performance for her.
And I can't help but wonder if that had affected her,
you know,
over those last couple of months.
I think that was just stylistic.
You know,
I just think the way she matched up with a Felice heric was just,
those two bulldogs are just clashing heads with each other.
They just couldn't get anything done.
Could be.
I mean that,
but that's again going back to the mental game,
a tremendous amount of stress to carry with yourself through these last six or
so months.
Well I hope she gets past that cause she's a lot of fun.
She's,
I like her a lot and I got to tell you man,
it's one of the most satisfying things.
Again going back to the golden snitch thing,
really my role here is as an advocate,
someone who looks out for athletes and situations like that.
There's been other things that that we do is look when we put this program
together,
the Sada program,
it was,
it's,
it's unprecedented.
There's no other professional sport that has the comprehensiveness of the
program.
There's also no other professional sport.
It's quite put together like the UFC is in terms of you have individual athletes
that you know are competing against each other.
It's not a team sport worth one person tests positive.
You have another person you know to step on in.
So a lot of what I've done over those first couple of years is take a look at,
you know,
hey,
we took,
we think it was a pretty good shot at the rules to begin with.
But look and see how those rules played themselves out.
As time went on and after about a year and a half,
there were a couple instances where I saw,
hey,
this isn't quite fair to an athlete.
We need to change that.
We did.
So after a year and a half,
there was a couple rules that we change.
The first one,
there's kind of a funny story behind this too,
was on if you remember when Nate fought Conor,
I think the second time he goes to the press conference after it takes out a
vape pen.
Do you remember that?
And someone asked him what he was doing and he said he was with CBD.
And at the time though,
the rule was the in competition period where CBD was prohibited,
lasted until four hours after the conclusion of the fight.
And he was clearly within that time period.
So you saw the contacted me and said,
hey,
you know,
technically Nate was in violation of this.
And I said,
hey,
look,
this was not the intent of the rule of this is,
you know,
and they never indicated that they were going to sanction him,
but I made it clear to say,
explain CBD for anybody that might not know what we're talking about.
Sure.
So CBD part of the,
you know,
the marijuana plant but is not psychoactive part of it.
Um,
I know a lot of our fighters anecdotally use it,
um,
for anti-inflammatory PR purposes.
Um,
I think,
I mean,
have you ever used it or what benefits is a anxiety?
It's,
it's great for people that are under stress.
It,
uh,
it,
it actually has a great response for that.
I know a lot of people that use it just for anxiety.
Um,
but anti-inflammation is,
is a big one.
That's the big one.
People use it for people with arthritis.
Love it.
Yeah.
Again,
comparing to,
you know,
a natural plant derived product versus a synthetic,
nonsteroidal antiinflammatory Advils Tylenol's can be toxic on.
Yeah.
Probably Common Sense.
Would would,
you know,
in addition to science would say that the CBD is maybe a little bit healthier
for you.
Um,
nevertheless it was prohibited in competition.
Is it still?
No.
So that was actually a rule change.
The water,
um,
prohibited list,
which we follow,
took it completely off.
The prohibited list started.
It's amazing.
2018 so that's great.
So we can just take CBD the entire time.
The training,
there's no,
it's obviously there's no performance benefit,
there's no psychoactive effect.
It just reduces inflammation and it doesn't have a natural way,
way healthier.
And it was the case before they can do it in training.
It was only prohibited in competition.
So weigh in day and fight day.
Now it's completely been taken off the list and it's okay to use it anytime.
That's fantastic.
So it was good.
So,
but we identified a problem with,
with the rules in that when Nate finished that,
that fight with Conor,
you sought it,
came to the post fight medical tent said,
Nate,
we need to make a collection from you.
And I don't know whether it was blood or urine,
but they got a sample from him.
He then went to the press conference after and it was on,
you know,
took the CVD.
What I said is,
look,
you can't punish him.
You have the sample that shows what was in his system.
Yes,
CBD was prohibited in competition,
but you have a sample to show whether or not he was using it.
It's clear that you know,
he was using it after the fight.
We just put those extra four hours in there with a thought of if a fight or
finishes a fight and somehow you saw it as not able to get to him,
say gets in the ambulance right away.
It goes to the hospital.
You increase that window just in case they can't get them.
Come to find out.
As we started putting this program together,
you saw it.
It can always get to that fight or after if they're transported,
they can hop in the ambulance with them and it wasn't an issue where we needed
those extra four months.
So we changed that rule.
And now I'm basically,
the rule is the in competition period ends with a collection immediately after
the fight or you know,
you saw it,
it has a reasonable amount of time after the fight.
Um,
so the funny thing is,
uh,
after we changed this rule,
Nate and Nick Diaz come to a fight and they're sitting,
call it the zoo for section,
you know,
Kinda Dana's section right there behind Dana's table.
So I go over to nick and Nate and I said,
hey Nate,
man,
uh,
hey,
we changed that rule,
you know,
the whole CBD thing.
And actually we kind of refer to it as,
as the Nate Diaz rule.
And when the Diaz brothers ratified,
I mean it's pandemonium and chaos.
Everybody's yelling their name and I literally,
I'm like,
I have the demon registered with them.
He didn't look at me,
he was looking somewhere else.
So about a month later,
Nate,
I see him,
I'm in,
I think it was in Vegas.
I'm in the kind of walk out 10 hole and here comes Nate.
So he sees me,
he comes over me,
gives
me kind of the bro Hug,
what's up,
he's with Yancey Mendez and so against the,
and I started talking and Yancy beyond being just an unbelievably entertaining
fighters.
One of the best dudes on the roster.
Great Guy.
So I'm talking against,
he all the sudden Nico's,
hey Jeff man,
tell Yancey about my usada rule.
I've got a sata rule named after me dog.
And so I thought,
man,
you're doing something right when Nate Diaz is like excited about a change in
that you sought a rule,
right?
Yeah.
That is a,
that is a very good rule.
I'm really excited about that.
Um,
what's the story with neck?
He can't fight?
Is he still have like some sort of a,
so yeah,
Nicholas will,
nick was our first fire that ran into the whereabouts issue.
So he got three whereabouts,
failures and a rolling 12 months.
So he's currently going through that process.
You know,
it's a tough one cause I don't want to fight.
I think he does.
I mean we've,
and I've sat down with him over the last couple months and talking about trying
to resolve this whereabouts issue.
I mean the unfortunate thing there is look the whereabouts failure sanctions are
meant to catch people that are cheating and trying to avoid testing.
And I just think Nick's lifestyle led to those three kind of whereabouts,
not that he was trying to avoid testing.
Um,
nick being nick,
we're trying.
Yeah,
we're trying to work through that.
He,
you know,
he put,
he trusted certain individuals to do his whereabouts for him.
Um,
I think is what happened over time and those individuals would come in and out
of his life and of course,
kind of unbeknownst to him that he was missing a lot of these things,
never less,
you know,
the,
again,
there's strict liability here and it's currently under sanction,
but we're hoping to resolve that pretty quick now.
Uh,
last time we,
you were on,
you talked about this,
a new potential testosterone that was derived from animals and that there might
be a way that people could take this stuff and go undetected.
Yeah.
I mean,
I haven't heard much about that since then.
Um,
was it just a theoretical?
No,
now it's out there.
It's real.
Um,
but you know,
again,
some of the things that to combat that or the biological passport program where
you're looking over time,
it's somebody t ratio and even though that,
you know,
won't trigger a positive on the isotope ratio mass spectrometry,
if you see wild variances and t ratios over time,
that could potentially trigger,
would there be a way to more violation,
sorry.
There was a way to mitigate that,
a biological passport thing by making a specific time that you inject it every
day and doing it on a regular basis.
Like instead of,
I know,
um,
it was one of the ways that,
uh,
some fighters have gotten caught is that they knew they were going to be in
Vegas or something for a long period of time.
So they couldn't take any and they,
maybe we'd take it twice a week.
So they doubled their dose and took it in a one shot and then they got hit with
a random and then it showed that they had this massive,
yeah,
it's a potential.
I mean,
you know,
someone who has the resources and sophisticated and somebody has someone who's
educated in chemistry.
Um,
it's,
it's definitely a cat and mouse game anti-doping.
And you know,
um,
Vogel talked about that when he was on here.
I mean the,
the premise of ICARUS initially it was right,
he was going to show that that anti-doping doesn't work.
And it was actually something I was,
I watched your podcast with them and watch the movie as well.
And initially I was a little bit turned off on that premise cause he gave,
he gave the examples of Armstrong.
Marion Jones just said,
look,
anti-doping just doesn't work and I'm going to go out and prove that that
doesn't make any sense.
If both those people got busted that right.
That's the reality.
But look how they did.
They got busted through the investigative element of anti-doping and that's
what's something that was learned and came out of I think the investigations I
was involved in and all,
you know,
you started does this,
water does this.
The drug testing is not enough.
You know,
drug testing is a necessity.
You need to have that,
but you also need to have a strong investigative element.
You have to liaison and you sought a does this with law enforcement throughout
the world.
Um,
so that if you can't catch somebody because they're sophisticated in the
techniques they're using,
you know,
maybe you catch them through,
informants or other investigative resources.
Pressure.
Exactly.
Now that documentary blew my mind.
It was incredible.
For people who haven't seen it.
It's on Netflix,
it's called ICARUS.
It's by Bryan Fogel and the documentary.
The premise was he was a guy who was a,
a cyclist and decided to compete in a race first clean and then come back and do
it again under the assistance of a guy who was an expert in anti-doping that
showed him like,
what's the stuff that you should take right along the line?
He makes friends with this Guy Gregory,
how do you say his last name?
Right.
Check off,
something like that.
Um,
and during this time period it's discovered that the entire Soviet Olympic team
is on steroids and that they cheated during the games.
It's Sochi and he explains how they did it and then the investigation comes down
and the guy has to flee Russia and then he comes to America.
He goes into protective custody and Bryan Fogel just,
you talk about like just stepping in shit.
Holy smokes.
Did he come across on many,
did an awesome job of telling the story and this Gregory God and making him kind
of the sympathetic character.
Yet he was the kind of the evil villain that was doing all this over in Russia
was just incredible.
A movie.
The one thing that he didn't cover too much in the movie,
it was a little bit disappointed is who really the true heroes were of that
whole thing.
So there was a husband and wife couple the tally and Yuliya Stepanova and um,
Yulia was an 800 meter runner for Russia and Vitaly actually worked for Rosado.
The Russian anti-doping organization has a drug collecting officer and they were
the ones basically that caused this German documentary to come out exposing what
Gregory was doing.
And then at that of time the heat came
on Gregory because this information was out there and he was either forced to
stay there and likely be,
you know,
arrested and put the blame on or flee,
um,
to the u s it was dealt with very briefly in that movie.
But those two I think were the true heroes because,
you know,
they just did this cause it was the right thing to do.
Um,
Gregory did it,
you know,
obviously with a lot of self preservation in mind and that he had one of two
choices.
Either take off and come clean or stay there and face the consequences.
But never less man.
Fogel did.
I thought an awesome job in that movie.
And just an incredible,
incredible story.
And it's,
it's really,
um,
you know,
tough,
I'm sure for Olympic athletes to say,
God,
man,
this is what,
what we're up against when you're talking about state sponsored doping and the
KGB being involved.
And there's almost a sense of hopelessness out there that,
you know,
how am I ever know that I'm as a clean athlete,
my rights are going to be protected.
Again,
going back to what we're doing with the UFC,
the beauty of what we're doing is you,
you can never see that because you have an independent authority.
You sorta who's operating and administering our program.
Um,
so unlike the Russian government where they have interest of Russian athletes,
you know,
doing well and winning gold medals,
you saw it.
I could,
you know,
in a sense,
give a crap about,
you know,
who's being,
who's being caught and isn't.
Um,
so one of the things that came up in the film that was really disturbing was the
collusion between water and the IOC and that they really,
it was in their best interest to not sanction Russia.
Yeah,
it's a con.
You have people sitting,
you still do on the,
on the water board and on the IOC board.
So there's,
there's a conflict of interest is wada is going to come in and say,
hey this was clearly state sponsored doping.
We're going to exclude Russia from the Olympics for the next,
you know,
however many years.
Well that's a hit to the IOC cause IOC is getting money from these television
networks putting on the Games in Seoul or in Tokyo coming up.
So you know,
a conflict of interest there.
You saw it as a nonprofit organization.
So the UFC,
the UFC does pay them to administer our program,
but it's not lining the pockets of anybody.
They're CEOs not making more money because of the UFC is here.
They maybe have a few more personnel to administer the program,
but you know,
if,
if we go away,
you saw is still in existence.
They're still doing Olympic testing and you know,
nobody's pocket books are hurting.
Yeah.
That independence I think is critical.
And that's something that you brought up earlier.
I think that's so awesome.
And you know what a massive credit to the UFC,
they decided to do it this way and not do it in house.
Just take on your protocol out of courage to do that.
And it takes a real commitment to try to clean up the sport.
Um,
one of the things that was really weird was like they banned some,
some teams from Russia,
like not all the sports but the sports they band where like nobody gives a fuck
about what,
what the sports wear.
Yeah.
Well I think in reality you could find out what,
what they banned,
they were going to ban the team,
but the outrage from that was just so strong.
And then they realize the economic impact of that would be literally in the
billions of dollars.
But think they abandoned track and field team from,
from Rio Games,
which is pretty significant track and field being a pretty big Olympic sport.
There was a new hair,
Russia banned from Winter Olympics,
but clean athletes can compete.
So this is new,
right?
Russia athletes make that a little bigger for my fucking shitty eyes.
It Russia has been banned from the 2018 winter Olympics in South Korea over the
country.
Systematic manipulation of anti-doping rules.
However,
Russian athletes who can prove,
prove that they are clean,
we'll be invited in in quotes to compete in say that Pyong Chang Look at Jamie
was degree in Korean.
Uh,
the International Olympic Committee said Tuesday,
so that's fascinating.
So they'll,
they'll be literally competing under the Olympic flag,
which is like woo.
It's the most wide ranging punishment ever met it out by the IOC in a party on a
participating nation,
let alone a powerhouse of the Olympic movement.
Yeah,
I mean,
you're competing on the Olympic flag,
but everybody's still gonna know the commentators are going still gonna say the
Russian athletes competing on the Olympic flag.
That's bizarre.
Right?
Competing,
I mean,
is this unprecedented?
Someone competing under the Olympic flag?
I'm not sure whether it's happened before.
Not Man.
How's it?
I'm pretty sure I remember just random people.
I don't,
they might not have had to country to perform or their whole country might not
have sent them,
but they would qualify or something.
Okay.
Wow.
Crazy.
Um,
but there was also a certain teams that were,
were kicked out of,
or certain gold metals that were a rescinded,
but that was the other thing that I thought was really interesting about you saw
it as,
um,
protocol is that they freeze samples.
So just in case the testing improves in the future,
he used to turn again,
it,
you know,
there's no denying it's a cat and mouse game going on out there,
but a deterrent is that it's not all of them,
but certain samples can be frozen up to 10 years.
And as new tests come online,
like the longterm metabolite tests that,
uh,
Gregory developed after five or six years,
they may go back and retest those samples.
And you know,
when we go out and educate our athletes,
I tell them,
look,
maybe you're not in the UFC anymore,
but your legacies around forever and you know,
that's a smear to your legacy forever.
And it's all about creating that.
My job,
I worked for the UFC,
my job is not,
hey,
let's see how many athletes we can catch.
My job is to try to get out there,
educate,
develop relationships,
and create that deterrent saying,
look,
you don't want to do this.
It's going to catch you eventually.
If you're going to do something,
I'll give you every resource and bit of knowledge.
I have to make sure you're successful under the program.
But you know,
success in my eyes is very few positive tests.
I don't,
you know,
right on the Kuwait,
the program with success because we've had,
you know,
60 or so positives over time.
I'd love to see,
you know,
none and see more of that.
Those graph showing those,
you know,
common
markers of a,
of a doper come more into line.
Right.
You're not in the position of a detective or a prosecutor anymore.
Your position is now an athlete liaison.
It is,
and it's,
it's a much different role.
There's a role I'd really,
I'd really enjoy.
It's probably a lot less stressful.
Definitely a lot stressful,
a lot less stressful.
And you know,
Dana says it all the time,
the importance level in the UFC and MMA is off the charts.
I,
I still have a strong belief in ethics and sports and beliefs.
Sports are so good for kids and teaching them life lessons.
It transcends sports.
My,
I have three daughters that,
you know,
played sports growing up.
A couple of them still do.
And I know when they get out into the real world and that work environment,
there's nothing,
they can't handle it because they've already handled it.
And Sports,
they've run up against a coach who's an asshole.
They'd run up against teammates that are selfish.
They've had great,
you know,
occurrences when they've worked well as a team.
All of that is going to come into play to help them in their lives.
And when you introduce something and something,
it's so pure and good that's breaking the rules.
Um,
that short term mostly longterm is not healthy for your sports,
is about to be healthy for you.
And at some level,
especially the way these performance enhancing drugs are used,
they're not really being used in a healthy,
healthy manner.
And,
um,
so yeah,
but I feel,
I feel very strongly and very positive about what we're doing and the role that
I'm playing here.
Well,
it's interesting that the UFC,
unlike a lot of sports,
the,
the history is pretty transparent and the history of doping is also
pretransplant.
Like everybody's really aware of what the wild west days where like,
I mean,
it's,
people talk about it,
they laugh about it.
It's,
it's sort of an,
it's not a secret at all in particular as we were saying about pride.
Um,
but you know,
I think that ultimately what sports should be about,
it should be about effort,
skill,
determination,
focus,
discipline.
And those are the lessons that you could pass on.
Not who has the best pharmacist,
not,
you know,
not who has the best team of scientists that can hide the results better.
And that's one of the more disturbing things about it.
Gris or,
or,
or any of these other things that have shown that,
you know,
there's systematic anti-doping or are doping or state sponsored doping.
It's just,
it distorts the whole thing.
Like what a victory is or why you've got some athletes,
it probably would have won anyway if everybody was clean.
They might've been the best athlete anyway and then they could have one.
Floyd Landis told me,
told me that all the time about lance,
he said that dude was the baddest ass bicycle rider ever and take away all the
drugs that were taken in the sport.
He would have been the best writer ever.
He had something going on there,
but the reality was everybody was using something men.
That's how fucked up sport.
Yeah.
I think I talked about this last time,
but I really,
you know,
people are surprised to hear this,
but I had a lot of compassion and understanding for a lot of these dopers after
they told me their stories.
I mean,
you're a young kid,
vulnerable kid that you know,
wasn't really worldly,
that all your teenage life,
you
aspire to go over to Europe and get on a bike and compete and he's awesome races
and all of a sudden you're over there,
dropped off in a coach,
sitting in a room says you want to stay here a kid.
Here's the program that were on Meth.
I heard one,
I heard a dozen of those stories,
grown men crying,
retelling those stories.
Um,
so yeah,
I mean I feel good about,
you know,
change in the culture in this sport radically.
I would love to have a podcast with you and lance sit down together and discuss
this now that the dust has kind of settled and you know,
he's been pretty open about it and transparent about the whole process himself.
Yeah,
I mean,
I think the difference,
the difference that that he has with everybody else is,
you know,
again,
this is back to [inaudible] contention that they didn't catch lance is you look
back at his history and they did actually,
you know,
in 99 I think he had a corticosteroid positive in 2001.
I think he had a test that showed,
um,
high likelihood of EPL use that wasn't followed on.
But what he did is he became very powerful in the sport and the International
Cycling Union was,
was corrupt and basically use that power and wield it and they cover it up.
Um,
a lot of those tests
crazy.
It is crazy.
And it's a,
and the crazy thing about combat sports is that we're not just talking about
crossing a finish line quicker.
We're talking about the ability to deliver more damage on your opponent.
And that's why it's so critical that people fight clean,
whole new level.
It's a completely different thing.
There's just really,
there's no comparison.
Now let's get into,
we briefly touched on weight cutting.
Um,
but I know that the UFC has recognized that there's,
there's a real issue and,
um,
what steps have we taken to try to mitigate the problems that are caused by
weight cutting?
Yeah,
it's interesting.
And another one of the reasons why I love the performance institute and the
staff that we had there and that before them.
And it really stemmed from the Usada program where under the Wada Code you
banned the use of Ivs.
And so,
cause I was kind of the point person obviously explained why ivy's or you know,
it goes back to the,
to the cyclist,
they were using ivs to basically flush their system of drugs to manipulate their
bicycle biological passport.
So if their blood doping or using EPO and um,
it would have a tendency to lower those and,
and normalize those biological passport levels.
And so a lot of learn that through some of the investigations that,
you know,
they were conducted and determined that ivy use,
um,
in excess of 50 milliliters,
every six hours would be prohibited.
So when we announced that we were adopting the water prohibited list and
prohibited methods,
um,
there was some,
some blow back within the UFC community saying,
hey,
these things are used regularly because fighters are pushing themselves to the
edge to make weight and do you understand what you're doing here?
You're going to put fighters and unsafe positions where they're going to get in
and not be,
um,
rehydrated.
So we took a look at that and spoke with you,
saw it,
and he said,
hey,
you know,
maybe we should,
slowly rolled out the ivy band.
So we actually delayed that by three months.
The program went into effect July 1st and we instituted the IB band,
um,
October 1st.
So we had three months of getting fighters prepared for it,
educating them why,
um,
that they were banned.
Nevertheless,
I mean,
real quickly the whole weight cutting issue came kind of into my plate.
And while,
you know,
I wasn't an expert in it,
I had to get out and talk to a lot of fighters,
camps,
coaches about ivs and give them,
you know,
alternatives to rehydrating the right way.
And so I,
again,
not being an expert myself,
I reached out to what I found were we're experts in the world.
A certain guy by name of Doctor Robert [inaudible] who is a phd exercise
physiologist,
works with the US Army Research Institute of Environmental Medicine Studies,
environmental effects on soldiers,
his expertise being dehydration.
So soldiers in the Middle East that are marching for hours,
days upon a time run out of water,
dehydrate themselves.
How do we get these fighters back?
Are these soldiers back rehydrated and back into the fight and thought,
hey,
this is the type of expert that we need to talk to.
Its extreme dehydration.
Not,
you know,
some kid that has diarrhea,
it's mildly dehydrated with some,
some pedialyte.
So we brought him in.
Um,
had him actually the week of UFC 200,
um,
he was in town,
got a chance to talk to a lot of the,
the fighters coming in and analyze the message they were using.
Um,
he recommended to us,
hey,
you know,
here's the maximum amount of weight fighters,
that you should recommend.
Fighters are losing that fight week.
And that's how we came up with our weight guideline of 8%.
So we recommend when those fighters checkin Tuesday for a Saturday fight there
within 8% of their goal weight,
usually on Friday.
I'm not a requirement or recommendation,
but you know,
we put that out there and educated heavily on that.
Um,
since then,
uh,
you talked,
I think last week about Andy Foster,
the executive director of California who's really taken the lead in terms of
commissions on combating dangerous weight cutting.
Um,
he worked with US pretty closely on developing his 10 point,
um,
weight cutting plan or plan to combat serious weight cutting.
Um,
includes his commission making calls to fighters on the car 30 days out,
10 days out,
making them a little bit more accountable,
uh,
farther out than fight week.
Um,
he's also got a provision where fight night,
he takes the fighters weight,
weighs them and their recommendation is you only put on 10% of your weight back
on plus a pound.
Um,
if they're over that California can recommend the fight or move up away class.
so really,
yeah,
I mean just a lot of,
you know,
education recommendations not here.
A lot of people talk about,
and I'm curious for your thoughts on this.
Hey we can,
we can stop instantaneous issue and instantaneously just put rules out there.
If you lose this much weight or put this much weight back on,
you're suspended for six months,
12 months,
you know,
whatever your,
we're just not going to let you,
you fight.
My concern there is when you have absolute rules,
fighter's going to do everything possible to you know,
to make weight.
Say you had a rule that if you miss,
wait,
you can't fight it again for 12 months,
you have to move up a weight class fighter's going to kill themselves to make
weight.
My fear would be that you,
you put an absolute rule out there and someone get hurts because of the rule
that you put in place,
which is a,
you know,
I think it's a measured approach.
You have to continually reevaluate it.
But I think right now the rules that are out there between our recommendations,
California has rules are more guideline recommendations.
And then that in conjunction with what we're doing at the performance institute
where,
I mean you saw last week,
there is no excuse if you have issues making weight or you're not sure what your
weight class is,
that you have every resource available the best in the world to you to come in
and find that out,
to be given a plan on how to safely then make weight.
Um,
so,
you know,
it's,
it's a multimillion dollar investment that the UFC has put I think toward that
problem and you know,
hey,
maybe two,
three years from now we say,
hey,
that was with good intentions,
but not enough.
We need to do more.
But I think right now,
um,
that's our strategy,
uh,
on the issue.
Well,
I think a couple things would have to happen to really stop weight cutting.
One thing you're going to have to blow up these weight classes because there's
going to be champions in these weight classes that really won't be in that
weight class anymore.
If you cut all the real heavy duty weight cutting out of the picture.
I think what one FC is trying to do is they're,
they're doing hydration test and they do a series of them.
I believe they do three leading up to the fight,
which really was it.
Benevidez was telling me this,
someone,
someone was telling me this,
that they've essentially made it almost impossible for you to cut weight.
So they do hydration test on weighing at the way they're doing hydration test
three different times,
three different times leading up to the fight.
I don't know the exact protocol,
but what they've done is essentially made it so that you can't be dehydrated.
Like you can't,
when you weigh in,
you have to weigh in and as you know,
like if you're fighting at one 70 but you know you,
you get on the scale and you're fucking dying,
they're like,
no,
you're not really one 70 like,
and that,
that's really where it should be.
This idea that the best way to fight is to cheat and to drain all yourself of
fluids and then pretend that you're 160 pounds,
then get back on the scale,
you know,
15 hours later at one 85 that's fucking crazy.
That doesn't make any sense.
You're not really 160 pound fighter.
You're 185 pound fighter who almost died.
Yeah,
it's interesting,
you know,
if I talk with forest a lot about this because he went through it and again why
he's such a great asset to the probe to the company,
uh,
but he says,
look,
there's certain and girls that have a genetic,
um,
ability to,
to carry,
you know,
they have good muscle mass.
Usually that just carry a ton of water and it's not,
it's not difficult.
It's not dangerous for them to drop 10 or 15 pounds and not,
but it would be if they fought 15 pounds under c,
if they're a fighting at 170 pounds,
they really weigh one 85 and if they cut down to one 70 they make that weight
and then fought right then.
Then it would be dangerous.
Their performance would be radically diminished.
So we're lying.
When those people get on the scale,
when they get on the scale and they flex and they say one 70 sure you're one 70
for about an hour,
you know,
and then you're going to go right back up to what you were before you dehydrated
yourself.
This is madness to me.
Well this goes against what fighting is supposed to be.
What we talked about before about discipline and focus and and and technique and
training.
That's what competing is supposed to be about.
It's supposed to be about a fight or two equally skillful individuals try to
figure out who's got the best strategy and who's got the best we'll and
technique.
It's not supposed to be about who can do this legal cheating thing best cause.
That's what weight cutting is.
Well you know,
really the modern history of the UFC and the reason I think it's so successful
is the Renzo and Dana ran toward regulation,
right?
Yes.
They said,
hey,
this is a no,
you know,
marketed as an no rules,
no hold bar event.
They ran toward rules.
And so I think you know what you're taught.
And I actually had a discussion with Bob Bennett about this executive director
of Nevada.
He's Graham last week and you know,
he's looking what California is doing says,
look,
we have physicals after the way in.
So you know,
we do the way it is now at the host hotel.
So it's usually done at a ballroom fighter,
gets up on the scale,
makes weight immediately,
goes behind the curtain and has their pre-fight physical.
Right.
But do they have a hydration test?
I,
they don't.
I know California does some hydration testing fight night,
but would,
Bob told me as I have the most experience,
ringside physicians in the world that have seen more combat sports events and
everywhere,
I'm comfortable that these guys are evaluating these medical professionals or
evaluating these fighters in the scenario and if they feel or see something's
not safe for that fighter to compete the next night,
that they'll call them off.
I think that's wonderful.
But I think all that does is keep fighters from getting to the point of death.
I mean,
getting to the point where they're sick and tear,
they're definitely compromised when they're making the weight.
They're not really at that weight.
What I would really love,
in a perfect world,
besides the bare knuckle thing,
what I would really love is a weight class every 10 pounds.
Just have every time.
I mean,
there's just giant gaps.
The gap between 85 and two oh five is 20 fucking pounds.
That's a lot of weight.
I hear that.
But let me give you a scenario where it shows that alone and can work female new
division for the UFC one 25 right?
Because we had a one 15 to one 35 pound gap,
right?
What happened in our first championship fight?
So Jara Eubanks couldn't make weight.
She didn't,
she
wasn't even,
you know,
so there,
that in and of itself,
just making a weight class,
I don't think solves the problem.
But she's also relatively inexperienced young to sport.
And this is a brand new way class that they really didn't have a,
I'm not saying he had more weight classes,
wouldn't help,
but they're not going to help by themselves.
You gotta it's gotta be a multiple prong attack.
I think the hydration test should be along with that,
the hydration test and weight classes every 10 pounds and then give the champion
the benefit of the doubt.
Like whoever is the champion,
each division,
whatever,
whatever weight class,
you know what we find out what they really way and they have an opportunity to
fight for the title in that weight class.
You have to,
I think we talked about it when you tour through the Pie,
but we have on a couple of occasion use that bioelectrical impedance machine to
determine is that the proper term?
I don't know.
Um,
but it basically can you step on the scale and you,
you hold onto these handles and it gives you some type of hydration reading.
Um,
we've done that a few times on checking day,
weigh in day.
We're not sure exactly what the numbers look like,
but that's something that,
you know,
we're looking into.
Clint also does a lot of specific gravity testing,
fight week on fighters where,
you know,
it'll be a Tuesday or Wednesday and I think he showed you that chart.
Um,
he'll look at how much weight fighter has to lose and then look at what their
specific gravity reading is,
how diluted or concentrated the urine is.
And you know,
if you see someone with a bunch of weight to lose that is,
you know,
relatively dehydrated specific gravity wise,
then you know,
it can alter their plan.
So yeah,
I mean we've got a lot of,
a lot of that stuff going on.
I don't necessarily disagree with you that that more needs to be done,
but right now our plan of attack is to use these resources,
use the facility of the pie.
You know,
in an ideal world,
I think rather than making these absolute rules,
trying to educate our fighters,
trying to show them,
I tell you one thing,
you can talk until you're blue in the face about things being bad,
unhealthy for a fighter.
They're like,
I'm bullet proof.
Not only that,
they're fighters,
they're fighting.
That's bad for you anyway.
Right?
Like,
oh,
cut and weights bad for me too.
Okay.
Where they start listening.
And I think this is where the performance institute comes into play when you
start talking about the effect on your performance.
Um,
so if you tell them,
hey look,
if you can come to you know,
your proper weight in a more measured approach and not lose a whole bunch and
put that what look,
look at the difference it's going to make on your performance 24 to 30 hours
later because you see this,
I mean you see this occasionally when fighters go through,
you know,
tough weight cuts.
You see them,
Sandra says after a round or two,
right?
Oh good.
He's looked moving up to 170 pounds.
I mean it's just phenomenal.
I also think now it's interesting,
there's,
you know,
on one side of it the criticism would be,
well you're just encouraging even greater weight cuts and regains.
But I think this morning weigh in thing that we've,
we've put together I think has had a positive impact in a couple of areas.
Explain that for people to know what we're talking about.
So actually Andy Foster again,
California before UFC one 99 came to me and said,
hey,
we've been doing this morning weigh in for a couple regional local shows.
Would you guys be interested in it?
Where we do it at the host hotel,
we do it,
you know,
we'd open the scales from 9:00 AM to 11:00 AM and the idea would be a fighter
gets on weight in their hotel room,
upstairs hops on the elevator steps on the scale.
They make weight,
they can start eating and drinking again right away with the idea of they don't
have to wait til 4:00 PM and extra know exactly what the idea of,
I think one of the dangers of,
you know,
weight cutting and being dehydrated is the amount of time that you're at a,
add a loss of that water.
And in the past when we'd have the weigh ins at an arena,
it would be,
the fight would have to check in downstairs.
Say the,
we had the way ends at four o'clock in an arena,
the firewood,
the fighter would check in downstairs that maybe two,
um,
two 30 the bus would leave.
I remember in Rio were in one time on a bus for an hour,
hour and a half to the arena.
Everybody's depleted and dehydrated on the bus ride you step on a scale and a
cold,
you know,
environmentally unfriendly arena.
You then get back on the bus drive another hour,
hour and a half.
You're talking multiple hours where these fighters are in a depleted state.
So I think the morning way and protects against that.
I think the other benefit we've seen out of it,
I think it's more of a longterm than a short term benefit is we've seen a lot
more fighters missing weight since we went to the morning weigh ins.
And I think that's a product of timing.
And that in the past you had four,
you know,
four or five in the afternoon,
you had all day long to cut weight and you would see fighters at 10 or 11 said,
I can't do anymore.
And a one or two o'clock I said,
no,
I can do a couple more pounds and just all day long now,
unless you're literally not sleeping the night before you fight,
you have a shorter window in the morning to do that.
And I think a lot of those myths,
weights has helped identify those fighters that I'm probably on the right,
the wrong weight class.
I can't make that weight of waking up,
you know,
five or six in the morning,
a couple hours,
and it's probably too much weight to lose.
And we've seen some fighters move up in weight class because of that.
We've also seen some fighters that have decided,
hey,
I gotta take this more professionally and hire a nutritionist.
Like could be,
it could be a number of Madoff who made weight easily for his last fight and the
fight before that obviously fell out of the fight because his body shut down and
he had to go to the hospital.
It'd be rehydrated.
Yeah,
I mean I again,
I don't think it's a one size fits all solution.
You have to be careful,
hey,
it'd be missed weight that last time went to the hospital.
You know,
a knee jerk reaction would be you,
you can't fight this weight anymore.
What we saw this time,
he just changed the way he did things.
He came in,
he was on wait the night before,
he had a couple of pounds to lose fight week.
So it can be done.
And again,
that reverts back to the performance institute.
I think there's no excuse now that if you're a new fighter and you're not making
a hell of a lot of money and don't have the resources to hire,
you know,
George Lockhart who ever,
have Clinton Wattenberg who's an ivy league educated Sports Dietitian that can
provide you all that remotely.
If you can't get to Vegas,
he'll give you a full plan over,
you know,
over the phone,
over email.
Um,
if you can get to Vegas,
not only will Clint plan things out for you,
but you have a kitchen and cooks and staff that will provide you that meal
throughout your whole fight camp that just want to be there for free.
So amazing.
The place is incredible.
And we will have a Clint and um,
Dunkin,
uh,
on the podcast.
Explain all that.
What's in that little silver?
Yeah.
So,
uh,
this is,
so one of the things that,
that we want to do with this program again is,
you know,
first and foremost,
it's to protect the UFC athlete,
protect the rights of clean athletes,
but we also want to influence other sports influenced anti-doping as a whole.
So you saw came to us earlier this year and said,
we've got some new technology.
What do you guys think about using your program to be the first to kind of roll
it out?
And so the answer was,
well,
is the science good?
Is it validated?
They said,
yeah,
it is.
Um,
I was actually at a,
at a conference mid summer back in New York and sat on a panel with Major League
Baseball Pga tour and the UFC and a bunch of anti-doping scientists there.
And they were talking about this technology and the other leagues.
We're asked,
hey,
you guys gonna Institute that?
And they're like,
Nah.
Um,
you know,
I don't,
I don't think enough stare and they went to me.
I'm like,
absolutely.
If you saw the science tells me this,
this works.
We want to be the first,
especially if it's more convenient and more efficient for our program.
So what this is,
is it's a leaching device and um,
you know,
until this came out basically to get any blood tests from a shit,
you got some scissors.
I,
yeah.
Nice.
That was ready for you
and tell this came out.
Basically any blood tests done from,
uh,
from our athlete had to be done with the phlebotomist.
The full on needle in the vein take out a vial of blood.
So with this leaching device,
it's got 30 micro needles in it.
The size about eyelash,
you put it up on your arm,
you hit this button and painlessly the microneedles reach into just the
capillary.
So just the blood of the top of the,
uh,
of the skin and draw out a small amount of blood.
And this,
this light turns red.
When that blood's drawn out.
Whoa.
The blood is then deposited onto a,
an index card.
It's called dried blood spot testing.
So a drop or two of blood on the four corners,
the cards then sealed up,
placed in the mail and sent to a water laboratory.
This is all have to be done on video so that no,
well you have a color.
It's not the athlete doing themselves can have a collector doing that.
I mean,
that could be the future where an athlete is doing it themselves,
but then facetime or something.
Exactly.
But,
but here are the benefits of that a,
and this is,
this is huge for me.
I want to make things as convenient for our athletes as possible.
So,
you know,
you talked to our roster and ask them,
would you prefer big needle stuck in the vein of your arm and a of blood taken
out versus completely painless,
um,
you know,
leach of some blood from your capillaries.
They're all gonna say,
obviously this,
you talk about cost.
So,
uh,
blood taken out of a vein in your arm requires a phlebotomist.
So in those cases where you saw it as doing a blood test,
they usually take a drug collection officer and a phlebotomist to take out of
the blood to take out the blood.
I mean that's,
that's a couple hundred dollars there.
Um,
a vial of blood needs to be cold shipped to the water laboratories.
Here you're talking about dried blood on an index card that just needs to be
sealed up.
It becomes tamper proof once it is and put it in the mail for 55 cents.
Wow.
Um,
so I think incredible efficiency,
convenience to the athlete for our program.
And again,
we want to lead and I think,
you know,
when you talk about a master's question regularly about local or regional,
and then may show saying,
hey,
this is great what you guys are doing for your program,
but how much does this program costs you?
And it is a multimillion dollar program in a year.
And they say,
Hey,
we love to do something like that,
but you know,
we can't afford that.
Something like this where now you cut your costs down from sending blood to,
you know,
for maybe thousand dollars to,
maybe a hundred dollars,
this device in one DCL going to collect it out and put it on a card.
I think it has some really great implications,
not just for the UFC,
but you know,
throughout the sport.
Can I see that thing?
Sure.
It was pretty bad ass.
Wow.
Incredible.
Um,
anything else?
Should we wrap this up?
We're good.
Yeah,
man.
I think I'm good.
Unless you got anything else doing an amazing job.
I mean,
it's just,
it's incredible.
The results.
It's a,
it's so cool to see the results on the biological passport that you get.
You guys could show it in a chart and,
um,
I mean it pretty much everyone agrees.
I mean,
it's just,
it's really changed the nature of fighting.
It really has,
it changed the sport.
It changed.
It's almost eliminated doping.
Yeah.
I really appreciate it.
As I told you,
I really appreciate the platform you have here.
Literally every fighter in and camp and manager,
you know,
on our roster watches this.
So it'd be able to get in and talk about these things.
Talk about that new technology.
We just use that actually I think rose Nama Junis was the first fight or that
you sought to try that out on,
so a center tax tactical.
Hey rose,
I heard they,
they did the leaching device and the blood,
the dried blood spot tests.
Would you think she said awesome.
It didn't feel a thing and she said,
my mind is blown by the tech how far technology's come here and that's a big
part of anti-doping and that deterrent when you're now saying look at how the
technology is evolving here and you get an athlete that thinks,
well you know I think I can out with them or out cat and mouse them.
They see shit like this that are going to think and perceptions almost as
important as reality and a lot of these occasions and they start seeing things
like this and that deterrent factors built up I think higher and higher.
Yeah.
It seems like at one point in time there was a race and the dopers we're just
like one half step ahead.
But now it seems like it's even,
and with the possibility of freezing your sample and then looking towards it to
the future,
it's not worth it.
Yeah.
I don't know if I call it even yet,
but that goes is definitely narrowing and you're,
you're affecting the way that dopers are doping these days.
I think you know,
now the,
the,
you know microdosing I think is big and it's,
it's difficult to catch microdosing but you've altered the behavior of the doper
from taking drugs really unabated to very small amounts of the benefits aren't
going to be as great.
I think you got to consider that a win for anti doping.
I think that gap continues to,
to narrow and when they microdose like what,
what it like say would that be like testosterone or something like that?
Testosterone Epo.
Probably the two most common vary how much of a window of detection matter of
hours,
hours.
But you know,
again,
going back to,
I think I might've told this story last time I was on,
but the Floyd Landis Lance days,
they were manipulating during the Tour de France and eight hour window.
So from 10:00 PM to 6:00 AM they wouldn't test them during the tour of the
thought was these guys are racing up side of the mountain for five,
six hours a day.
We got to let these guys sleep.
And they figured out,
hey,
if we do something at 10 oh one by 601 there are list of tests or can come.
It'd be clear.
Um,
so you know,
yeah,
that prospect's all is out there.
That's why the UFC program,
there's no limits on the test now.
Right.
It's just a bummer.
It's in terms of their sleep side is,
yeah,
it's brutal.
But I think,
you know,
I think most appreciate that that's,
that's the price of,
you know,
clean sport and tried to ensure,
would there be a way to change that?
Like would there be some sort of a wearable device that would detect changes in
your body?
I've often thought that.
How about a wearable device?
It was top secret.
They collected everything 24 hours a day that you peel it off after a couple of
weeks and it's,
and it's tested or give them the wearable device.
So when they're sleeping,
so you don't interrupt our sleep cycles.
So 10:00 PM to 8:00 AM or whatever it is that you decide it would be the window
that they need to sleep.
While they're doing that,
they must have this device on that detects any changes to their metabolism,
any changes in input,
and then they can't eat while they're on.
This is we,
believe me,
the anti-doping community is always thinking about things.
I talked to Travis Tygart,
the CEO of Usada last week,
and he,
you know,
he made it clear and that you saw that I think dedicates $3 million a year
grants toward research and anti-doping,
things like that.
So I mean that,
that race is always going on and is always continuing.
Beautiful.
Great work.
Mr Novitsky,
I'm sorry about the nickname.
Oh,
get over it.
You're okay with us right off the bat.
Beautiful.
Thanks brother.
Appreciate it,
man.
All right.